This is Jocko podcast number one 23 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Now,
this podcast is the third in a series of podcasts that I've done,
and if you haven't listened to podcasts,
number one 21 and one 22 then go back and listen to those episodes before you
listen to this one.
The first of those podcasts,
number one 21 tells the story of chesty puller.
The iconic and heroic Marine Corps legend that fought in five wars was awarded.
Five Navy crosses the most of any servicemen ever where he retired as a three
star general.
After rising through the ranks
from private
podcast,
one 22
tells a much different story.
It tells the story of chesty polars son,
Lewis Polar Junior,
who also joined the Marine Corps
who fought in Vietnam,
who is horrifically wounded and continued to fight against pain and against loss
and against depression and addiction when he returned home from war.
Then in the end,
he lost that battle
after falling back into the downward spiral of alcohol and prescription pain
killers.
He became another statistic.
Rob The most dreadful kind.
He turned the gun on himself and took his own life
and as I said at the beginning of this series,
I was seriously questioning whether or not I could do this podcast.
Okay.
If I had the where with all to gut through the pain
of that story and more important if it was the right thing to do for is the
right thing to bring this story to light
because clearly the story does not have a happy ending.
Yeah.
You're not wondered if there was any good at all to be found in it.
Yeah,
but I also know that darkness left on checked and ignored is darkness that
grows.
Okay.
And if we do not learn from the past,
then we know we are condemned to repeat it.
Yeah.
There was one more compelling thing that allowed me to go forward in producing
this series of podcasts.
About a year ago,
I think I was in Texas and I was speaking at the Chris Kyle memorial benefit.
Then I met someone there.
He was a marine,
his uncle was a marine,
his grandfather was a marine.
Then he had been severely wounded in Iraq
and as I learned more about him,
I came to understand the hell he had been through as much more than just
physical.
Like many veterans,
the psychological wounds were also severe,
but he had fought against the pain,
fought against the loss,
fought the fight that so many other veterans fight and he had come out the other
side stronger and better and have dedicated his life to helping other veterans
win that fight.
His name is Jacob Shick
and it is an honor to have him on the podcast with us here tonight.
Jake,
welcome to the show,
brother.
They should have me real.
Thanks for coming on,
man.
You,
but I'm here to help.
Well,
I know you help a lot of people and I want to hopefully get you out there and
reaching even more people or you,
you,
you would,
when I first met you,
it was just talking to you.
I don't know.
I probably spent a couple hours at some random bar in a hotel somewhere in
Texas.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you know,
I was like,
man,
I told you.
Then I said,
you got to call them,
get on my podcast.
But when I was,
like I said,
when I was doing,
when I was reading these books,
I was saying to myself,
I gotta have,
I gotta show the other side,
man,
I've got to show that,
that you can get out of this,
and you'd get through it and there's no better example of that then did you and,
and the fight that you've been through.
So let's get into it,
man.
Let's start.
Let's start at the beginning.
Let's start
with the young Jake.
A lower did I blocked out most of my child when we talk about Louisiana,
Bossier city,
is that how you say it?
Back in the day,
but now that was what that was until you were what?
12 eight 10 is book.
Boser city.
Bose your city.
You could,
depending on what part of Louisiana here from and pronounce.
I like that.
The other way.
The wrong way.
No,
they're both right.
And both sides of Louisiana will will tell you that to nice.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I went to Texas when I was
about 12 and,
um,
moved in with my mom.
So I went from like a structured,
disciplined home to the antithesis of that,
which caught up to me pretty quick.
Huh?
Yeah.
And so what do you now your grandfather's marine was in the Marine Corps?
Yeah,
grandfather served war to fall on the wall and it survived and was,
um,
you know,
obviously the,
the driving factor of my interest of being a marine and because I was really
close to my grandmother growing up and my grandfather passed away fairly young
in his fifties.
And,
um,
you know,
there's a lot of questions about how he passed away and um,
but,
but we'll never know.
Right.
I mean,
so,
but my grandmother would talk about my grandfather and her chest is just swell
with pride.
You know,
I was the baby of the family.
And so when I would see that I,
I just thought to myself,
and when she talks about me,
I want her to do that same thing.
So it looks like I need to be a marine for that to happen.
Because every time she would talk about him,
something from his time in the service in the marines would be very close to
that sentence.
And I knew I want whatever that is.
And at eight years old I made my mind up that I'm,
I'm getting that no matter what it takes,
I'm going to get that.
I mean the only alternative was death.
That was the only thing that was going to stop me from getting it.
And uh,
he and my grandma and my,
and my uncle served in a non and was the second generation marine who's still
very much alive and uh,
it,
he's,
you know,
pretty,
he's pretty salty and it was funny man,
because before I went to boot,
I talked to him,
was sent off.
Jack know I'm about to go,
what do I need to know?
This is all he said.
I said,
be loud,
be facet,
don't volunteer for anything.
That was it.
So I'm on the phone and like waiting for the follow up.
I was like,
okay,
that's it.
He loud be fast,
don't volunteer everything I got to go,
I'm hungry.
And you know,
it's funny,
man,
as he's right.
That's really,
you know how many young dudes I've told that to?
They're like,
Hey,
what do I need to know?
I bet you I've said that three dozen times to in front of,
it's almost the complete opposite of what were the master chief of seal team one
until we were not going to there.
And he said,
keep your,
keep your mouth shut,
keep your ears open.
Don't forget anything and don't be late.
That's what he told me.
And,
and you've,
I volunteered for everything.
I was dumb but fired up.
I was a fire it up kid.
Well not a lot.
Not Lots of changed.
No,
it's actually interesting because in the,
in the,
in polar juniors book he's talking about as,
as they're in there in the basic school and they're getting ready to select for
what they want to do and they start getting graffiti on the desks and people are
like a motor t and out in three who gives a fuck drive a truck and they're just
being there like not all of them.
A lot of them started looking toward going,
hey man,
you know what,
I don't want them to that.
And very few of them were saying,
Hey,
I want to be an infantry platoon commander.
And that's what a lot of them got where they wanted it or not.
Maria in the middle.
A lot of them got war rather they wanted it or not.
Yeah.
Well like I was just telling you
he was,
he was ocs.
Basic School,
20 days leave in Vietnam is between the commander.
Oh,
welcome to the courtroom.
Yeah.
Just when you think the green,
when he can't get any harder,
you know it,
it can,
there's no limit.
I mean it's just true.
It's like a man with me.
It was never,
I never question,
you know,
I became a decent football player when I got to Texas,
which is basically how I graduated high school,
not basically that's how I got to high school.
I was lucky enough to be selected as a captain my senior year and I played for
five a Texas football team,
which was,
it's the real deal in Texas,
man.
And it's just under the NFL in terms of how many times our team would get
together and we'd be like,
we would like list out all the college teams.
We were totally sure we could beat just young and stupid man.
I'm bumming.
And it's just,
it's crazy cause you see the,
the athleticism difference between,
especially when you go to your big schools and the,
and the NFL,
it's the speed.
It's crazy in the strength it,
I mean all of it,
the agility,
it's night and day.
It's night and day and it just goes to show these young kids,
you don't know shit.
You think you know a lot.
You don't know shit.
I mean,
I was that way and I mean we'll really,
I still don't Marcia and I'll be 36 this month and I,
you know,
I mean anyone who comes up to me and they're like,
hey,
I got it figured out.
You know what I said?
Perfect.
You no longer need to be in my circle because I'll never learn anything from it.
I know I'm going to die a student of life.
But man,
I,
I was,
I loved football.
That was,
that's what I thought high school was for,
you know,
and so it,
it was the old cliche thing.
It was semi small city.
Um,
where in Texas where your top hill Cappell Copt ELL locale boys and uh,
you know,
had it not been for the,
for like my counselor and the principal and all those people,
like I wouldn't have graduated because I was pretty spent from the,
the political crap by the time,
you know,
my senior year rolled around and I just didn't know if I wanted it.
I didn't know if I wanted to deal with it anymore.
You know,
I didn't know if I wanted to
play the game that comes with playing the game and it just got to where it was
like,
you know,
this is,
it's kind of bullshit cause it's like growing up,
right.
And small town in Louisiana where you go to church every Wednesday,
every Sunday morning and you put on your Sunday best and you go to church and
you act a certain way or you're out in public and you act a certain way.
You know,
because you get home and the doors close.
That's all bullshit.
I mean we're being conditioned as little kids like,
hey,
just,
just fake it till you make it.
And
I'm all right saying that now.
So you got,
so when you were in high school,
you kind of got tired of playing the game.
You were just thinking now,
didn't you join the Marine Corps?
Yeah,
beginning of my senior year it was,
I was already 18.
I didn't tell anybody that was a good idea.
And that one over famously with my dad,
cause my dad thought I was going to go play ball at a small school because,
uh,
because I miss more days my senior year.
Then I actually went to,
well,
because when football season was over I was like,
sweet,
I'm done.
Yeah,
that's it.
I'm like,
I don't need to do this school shit anymore.
It's overrated.
But I knew it was not,
you know.
Did you join,
were you planning to go active duty or were you in the reserves?
No.
So I'd signed up in my recruiter who I'll never forget.
It was a,
he was legit,
man.
You hear a lot of like,
horror stories about recruiters.
I literally have a question in here.
I was like,
how was your recruiter?
Because so many people have good recruiters stories one way or the other.
They either screwed him or totally took care of him.
So my recruiter,
first of all,
he got me out of a lot of stuff where I was like,
dude,
we're nowadays,
there's no way it just wouldn't fly.
And I was like,
how the hell did you do that?
Don't worry about it.
You just better be at maps.
Want to tell you to be at Max my Bro,
you can drive me if you want.
But he,
uh,
he had,
so they,
you know,
most recruiting stations are like inside a shopping center or whatever.
So they were right next to like a big grocery store chain.
And,
uh,
one day some,
some dude goes and still some stuff and,
and uh,
he chases him down and like whips his ass in the parking lot.
So he was a firefighter in the core,
right.
So,
and I volunteered for infantry.
I was like,
I'm going to be on a big drunk.
He tried to talk me out of it for months.
It's like,
Jake,
you really don't want to do.
I was like,
no,
that's what I want to do.
And uh,
but he chased the dude down and I was like,
see,
that was for me,
that was affirmation from God that I'm doing the right thing,
you know,
these are my people,
this is where I'm supposed to be,
you know.
But it was,
man,
I,
um,
my second,
I think it was the second week of football season and,
uh,
I jacked up my right knee,
my MCL,
my right knee and,
and uh,
when I went and signed the paperwork,
I was on crutches and then in a brace.
And I opened the door and like hobbling and he goes,
what are you doing?
I said,
I'm sure you sign up.
And he goes,
not like that.
You're not,
you know,
I said,
give me two weeks.
We're playing whoever we were playing.
I said,
I'll be on the field,
give me two weeks.
And he was like,
there's no way.
I said,
okay,
be here in two weeks.
And he showed up and I played.
It hurt like hell,
but I played through it,
lied to my trainers,
lied to the coaches,
was like,
no,
I'm good,
I'm good.
You know,
just the young dumb like,
you know,
power before Iq,
right.
Just power through.
If you can just power through,
you don't really need the Iq and that's what it'd be stupid.
You gotta be tough.
That's it.
That's it man.
And there's a lot of truth to that,
which we can all attest to that.
Every person,
I don't care.
I don't care if you have a pecker or not.
You can attest to that.
If you're going to be stupid,
you better be tough for sure.
And so we,
but I ended up playing and,
uh,
I signed up,
I didn't tell anybody.
And then it was actually,
uh,
I graduated by the grace of God and because of high school football in Texas.
And it was,
uh,
it was amazing man,
because my dad actually met my recruiter at the high school graduation and he
was in his dress blues,
which is,
you know,
the best uniform there is.
No one can argue.
And if you do,
you're just stick.
But he,
he walks up and I said,
Hey dad,
you know,
I'd like you to meet my,
my recruiter.
And he looked at me and my recruiter held his hand out to shake his hand.
And my dad looked at me and he said,
and your dad did,
was this your dad finding out?
Yeah.
Oh Dang.
Let me,
I said,
why would you do that?
And then he looks at marker.
It looks back at me like waiting for me to answer.
I said,
dad,
I would shake his hand.
You're,
you're a banker.
I would shake his hand.
Pretty sure he could take you.
And uh,
he,
he was pissed,
man.
He was pissed because he's,
and I didn't understand why at the time really,
you know,
but later on,
this is 2000,
right?
This is,
uh,
yeah,
2001 actually,
I was at my graduation.
So this is may,
may or June,
2001 okay.
So,
yeah,
this is [inaudible] I'm already signed up.
I'm in,
I'm going.
And he,
your dad's thoughts were more around like,
hey,
you should go to college,
you should get a job.
You know,
I'm a banker.
It's a good life,
that type of thing.
You don't need to go and do this other stuff.
Exactly.
And so,
and so my thing was,
cause there's no war going on.
You know what?
No,
I'm so,
yeah,
no,
I mean it was,
it was quote unquote peacetime and which we all know there's,
those are saying,
but whatever,
you know,
whatever,
rainbows and roses and lollipop's people want to have in their safety bubble.
But we,
you know,
we,
I knew that that was,
that's what I was destined to do.
I knew like,
I felt it,
as much as I know that,
like my legs never going to grow back.
Like I knew that much,
that this is what I'm supposed to do.
And I was held men on it hell bit.
And so when my dad was pissed,
I was,
I questioned it because maybe I didn't tell him.
I kept it from him in a myriad of things.
Right.
I mean,
it's never just one thing.
Anything is never just one thing.
Like I love people like,
well,
I know what the problem is.
I'm like,
well,
what do you want to bet?
There's more than one because it's,
it's just the way it is.
But he,
I didn't realize and I didn't think about,
you know,
at the time I'm,
I'm 19 at this point and I didn't think about,
he had seen what war does to not only a person,
but someone that is his blood is flushing blood.
He's seen the after effects.
You know,
he used to,
he saw him with his dad and you all was that his dad was at your mom's house?
That was my dad's dad and his brother.
His older brother.
Yeah.
And so he had seen the after effects and seeing,
you know,
my grandfather was a hard man and,
um,
you know,
the way that he was the man when it was okay to be a man.
And you wouldn't get judged for being a man.
Whereas now that's a lot.
I mean,
don't act like you don't want to help talk about it because now it's like,
but you can use either bathroom.
That's okay.
Yeah.
I'm looking at you with a blank stare because I'm like detached from all that.
Like all that political,
I don't even,
it's weird man.
My life is weird that I don't,
I just kind of evolve and revolve in my own little world.
So when I,
when I hear like when I do,
when that kind of stuff enters my world,
I'm just kind of like,
is that really happening?
And it doesn't really compute and I move on.
I Dunno.
I don't.
Well see,
but when you,
but when you're in my world,
it's almost,
you have to know.
It's all,
I mean,
unfortunately with what we're trying to do.
Yeah.
It's,
well,
it's a big ass mountain.
We're trying to move man.
And it's,
but anyway,
I,
I go to,
I go to boot and I'm actually nine 11 happens.
Yeah.
I'm in my room the night before.
And the whole thing behind the reserves was,
so I thought about it and I was like,
okay,
so when did you graduate?
In May of 2001.
Yup.
You screw around for the summer.
Being a Texas kid that graduated from high school,
let's go into the Marine Corps.
Oh yeah.
That,
that was a real PG rated situation.
100% then,
then September 11th happened.
When's your bootcamp?
When are you leaving for boot camp?
Boot camp.
I leave for bootcamp the month after nine 11 check.
So it's all,
yeah.
And so it was,
um,
nine 11 happens.
And so the way I looked at it,
it was like,
okay,
you know,
my,
my grandfather was corporal Schick.
My uncle was corporal Schick.
I'm going to raise the bar for whoever fourth generation is.
I mean,
cause that's what we're supposed to do,
right.
For those that come after us.
And so I was like,
okay,
I'm going to join the reserves still infantry.
I'm always going to stay after he wanted to be a career infantry men.
And then,
um,
I'll pick up the five.
By that time I'd already had my degree.
And then I'll get up,
I'll get my commission,
then I'll be a Mustang.
So whoever the fourth generation is the bar set like that.
So that was my mindset,
right?
Obviously Johnny G.
Dot.
Had different plans but we,
but nine 11 happens and man it was,
I mean it became very real,
very quick that,
oh,
okay,
well this is,
I mean I was gung ho about it,
but my and my buddy,
we wake up and um,
my,
my mother walks in my room,
like opens the door and beer cans,
like get pushed everywhere.
So first she's like,
what tiles?
And then she's like,
turn on the TV,
you were under attack.
And I turned on the TV,
I looked at my buddy and we went to the,
we did the buddy system and the core.
And um,
I looked at him and I was like,
Bro,
we're going to war check.
And it was when it,
you know,
for a 19 year old kid you have that sense of let's rock and roll.
But then the smart little,
little smart person that lives in the back of your head,
it was like,
this may suck,
like this may suck bad.
Yeah.
But,
um,
it didn't obviously didn't deter my,
uh,
my motivation in doing that.
And so we,
yeah,
man,
I left the moth after nine 11,
which was,
you know,
I was right down the street from here and Mcrd San Diego man.
And He,
let me tell you something,
as if Marine Corps drill instructors need any more motivation to be Marine Corps
drill instructors.
They had an 11th,
they were ready to get some,
they had it.
It was gnarly.
But no matter from the time that we landed and the time that we got on the bus,
which this was something that always cracked me up because you land,
you can see the depot from the runway,
but for whatever reason,
the bus ride takes like an hour and a half,
you know,
that's welcome to the military in general.
It didn't take long for me to completely understand why that is the way it is.
And so it was,
um,
but from the time,
the first time I stood on the yellow footprints up to him,
now up to this point right now,
today I wouldn't question.
I don't question any of it.
I don't,
I wouldn't take any of it back.
I wouldn't trade any of it.
Um,
I have no doubt that everything has happened exactly the way it's supposed to
happen.
I don't believe in coincidences and I wouldn't take anything back.
I mean,
just because something that I've learned at the ripe old age of soon to be 36 is
that you have triumph without trials and tribulation.
Tragedy.
Those are kissing cousins.
You know,
you can't have one without the other.
And where do you go with it is up to you.
And,
uh,
you know,
my life was one hell of a roller coaster ride and it started the first time I
still do on those yellow footprints.
Yeah,
I mean,
and it started way before that man started.
You know,
I definitely had trauma before the trauma,
I think.
I think majority of us do because we live in a very spoiled first world society.
And we forget that we're mere mortals.
She's on the special about us.
We're all the same.
We were all just living,
breathing a skin jack,
you know,
that's it.
And so I,
when I started boot,
it was,
it was one of those deals where the,
the mindset started of the NRD had some leadership skills,
thanks to football and team sports.
And I had,
I'd learned that growing up and then in high school I really got to hone those,
those leadership skills,
which really helped me and boot.
I mean,
I really believe in team athletics because it's,
it's like everything.
No matter what you're dealing with,
the greater good is always going to be bigger than you always.
And you have to hang on to that humility in that I'm just,
I'm just a dude.
I'm just a dude being a dude.
They're bench to do playing the dude's trying to be another dude.
But you know what,
I'm,
you know what I mean?
It's you,
you,
you realize often if you're really trying to do something that's worth doing,
you reminded often how human you are.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
I used to tell my guys,
if you're doing something for the right reasons,
you're going to win in the end.
Like,
and that means if you're doing something that's going to help the team win,
you're gonna win.
In the end,
you're going to get what you want.
The things are gonna go the way you want.
If you're doing something for your selfish reasons or for the wrong reasons,
you're going to lose in the end.
Now you might both of those,
the person that's doing it for the right reasons might lose some battles along
the way.
The person that's doing it for the wrong reasons might win some battles along
But the end game person,
if you're doing the right things for the right reasons,
if you're looking out for the team,
if you're doing it for the good of the team,
you're going to win.
And if you're doing the opposite,
eventually you're going to lose.
That's the way it works.
You're 100% right.
I mean,
and you know what?
The history books,
they'll get it right?
They do.
It's not about every time we get on it takes,
sometimes it takes years,
sometimes it takes 10 years,
it takes decades.
But the people that are doing the right things for the right reasons,
they win.
Yeah.
And that's like a,
it's like I tell guys all the time,
which I still,
the,
the human reality in me still has three.
I have to remind every time I talked to a guy,
when I say guide me,
man or woman,
doesn't matter.
But every time I talked to him,
I usually start the conversation out with no matter what comes on her out of
this hole underneath my nose,
I need you to know I'm talking to myself too every time.
Yeah,
sure.
And I said,
it's,
I say,
you know,
it's none of our business.
What the hell other people think of us.
It is none of my business what anyone else thinks of me.
It should have very little impact on any decision I make every day.
All Day.
None.
It should,
it should have no impact.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's an interesting dichotomy in that,
and I've talked about that on this podcast before,
because for me,
right,
I'm a guy that on the one hand I exact same thing,
like I don't care what people think at the other end of the spectrum,
I absolutely care what,
what everyone thinks.
And I'll draw you into this when you were doing something,
I mean,
when I was doing something in the seal teams,
I'd be thinking always like,
hey,
is this the right thing?
What,
what's this gonna do to my reputation?
What am I got?
One is what is,
you know,
my buddy gonna think of me if I cut the corner here,
if I don't do the right thing.
So my reputation,
the way I was looked at,
I did feel that pressure all the time.
And at the same time,
if someone was like,
oh,
I don't like your clothes or whatever,
I don't care at all.
But things that I cared about and from people that I cared about and respected,
I always had the attitude that like,
yeah,
you know what?
I do care what they think I do care.
What my,
you know,
I'll tell you what man,
one of the hardest things I had to do what I wrote a book
and like here you are,
you're going to write a book.
You know you're going to write a book about yourself.
It's,
it's,
it's a arrogant,
conceited thing to do.
No matter what you say in the book,
it doesn't matter.
It's your writing a book about,
about you and,
and you know,
lay,
who wrote the book with me,
same thing.
The primary concern for me was like,
what are my Bros in?
The team's going to think of me.
Right?
So
that's hard.
But there's,
so there's a balance between those two though,
right?
All right,
let me,
let me simplify it.
The people that you're never going to meet.
Yeah.
So I'll Barney style for you those times you need to dumb things down for this
guy over here.
Everyone at this table,
let's just be honest.
You,
the people you're never going to meet through,
we'll have little to no impact on your life and you and your wellbeing,
hence forth.
It doesn't matter.
They think they matter and that's okay.
Let them think what they want to think,
but it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Now that's 100% right for sure because it's real easy,
especially in the line of work.
Then we do that.
We do day to day.
It's going to feel that it's real easy for people to sit on their self loading
asses behind their computer screen and pass judgment.
When we continue to grind onward in the face of tremendous loss,
there's something to be said for that.
I mean that's that.
That right there is a test of will and character all.
It's all in the face of tremendous loss to say,
okay,
we have to step back,
we have to reassess and we'll readdress what we engage.
Let's adjust our left and right lateral limits,
but,
but they're still grounded.
Take and demons.
The sleigh we have to move forward and burn.
Our pain is fuel because that's what we do.
Cause if not us who?
And so that all that started when I was standing on those yellow footprints
because you had this and it's something that you would re people that know their
stuff about the military agrees with.
One thing that can be said about the Marine Corps.
No other branch,
regardless of division,
adheres to tradition as much as the marines.
I mean you,
you asked me about about chesty and I'm like,
yeah,
I mean we told them good night every night for three months.
The Marine Corps is absolutely,
absolutely correct.
Yeah.
The Marine Corps does not play around when it comes to tradition.
And I think that there's
the proof's in the pudding,
right?
I mean,
since 1775 we've shown that.
We'd hear to that and that's what makes us who we are.
And that's why it's,
I think that
we have the success rate that we have regardless of being the bachelor children
or the military.
Oh,
not really knowing who her dad is and being poor it,
we make it work.
We,
we have since day one,
been able to really define what improvise,
adapt and overcome means we've been able to live that.
And prove situations where outside looking in that's gonna.
It's a,
it's a total loss and come out with a w come out with a victory because of that
very tradition that makes us who we are.
Because when all else fells,
all you have is your gut or,
yeah.
Now when you're going through boot camp though there was,
was there any combat veterans there?
I don't think we had one.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a testament to what you're talking about,
right?
Is that even though no one had been in combat in,
well they're probably be a few guys that went to Gulf War.
Maybe there's a couple of guys who went to Somalia,
maybe a couple of guys that went to grenade or something or,
or Panama may be,
but those are like onesies and twosies and there's a chance that like none of
your dis had any combat experience and yet the lessons get passed on you.
I had a old,
old Vietnam on here and he was talking about when he came back from Vietnam and
he instituted this certain type of training at out in the desert.
And I was like,
I went through that training and he's like,
yeah,
well I put that together like the same,
but it's appointment course where they put,
we'd be traps and put targets to shoot at and all this stuff.
I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
okay.
I made that up and I was like,
oh,
we still do it.
We still do it.
And that
tradition in the Marine Corps is like 200 years of things being passed down.
Right.
Solid.
I mean,
it's something that,
he listened to it.
Even now it makes me swell fried,
you know?
Like I understand why my grandmother reacted the way she did truly now.
Yeah.
You know,
and I've,
I've been able to live that.
I've been blessed enough to,
to live this journey that,
I mean,
yeah,
it comes with a lot of pain and a lot of hard lessons,
you know?
I mean,
pain is inevitable.
Suffering is optional.
That's something I've learned to,
you know what I mean?
It's no one's going to be harder on you than you.
Every day you wake up,
you should just be thinking to yourself,
all right,
today it's me versus me.
Yeah.
You know,
and no one wakes up and goes,
I'm going to go out of my way to be average today.
Like if you wake up and do that,
you need to have a gut check.
So,
so you get,
you get done with boot camp and then you go to Pendleton for,
for infantry China Soi went up to a Pendleton and um,
you know,
it's was fun man.
You know what sucks is in boot.
I was,
um,
I was first squad squad leader up until like a week before graduation.
I think it's just cause of the senior drill instructor didn't like me.
Uh,
I didn't like him either of those,
so it was mutual.
But um,
and there's one I had that I swear if I saw him on the street today,
like I'd go find them right now.
I'm not kidding it all.
There was one dude that I got had pts from that guy because he was going out of
his way to try and mentally break me and it just never happened.
And,
uh,
what do you,
what do you think,
why was that?
I think it was just,
it became this personal thing to him because he saw how other recruits would
gravitate.
Three might've been like jealous of your,
my Downer batch will be your,
sure.
I don't doubt it at all.
I don't know.
I mean,
cause he was ugly.
He was not handsome like yourself know,
and obviously I mean moneymaker Bro.
But he,
he was,
um,
but he was,
you could tell the underneath it all like he was,
he was a great marine.
And um,
he,
yeah,
we lied a lot for that guy and few other Duis.
But you know,
it was just,
I was thankful for our bootcamp with the last name,
like Schick,
you know what our guides last name was Schmidt.
Her,
that's nice.
So for three months he should or go get your brother Shit.
Three months,
man.
The only time I ever got emotional and bootcamp was on the parade deck and
graduation to when a is the one of the DISB had,
he looked at me and he,
he said,
I got to tell you,
Schick and the,
I heard the cook and I got emotional.
Like,
dude,
I got my name back.
I turned her back.
But,
um,
he told me what he told me.
And then my dad was there actually in,
in walks by me on the parade deck and tosses mechanic Copenhagen.
Wonka didn't even look at me and he said,
good job,
let's go eat and like keeps walking.
So I was like,
okay,
still pissed.
I get it.
Yeah,
yeah,
dude.
But it was,
you know,
and like I said,
they're there for years.
I didn't get it.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
go up to soi to Pendleton.
And um,
I loved every minute of that too.
Here's what made it awesome for me,
and this is something that a lot of the listeners will relate to,
is that no matter how gnarly it got and boot or how gnarly it got an Soi,
or how tired or hungry or just beat down you were mentally,
physically,
emotionally,
there were all you had to do was look to your left or right,
because guess what?
So are they.
Yeah,
but you go to fall down.
They're right there to pick you up.
No matter how tired you are.
Who doesn't want that?
Yeah.
You can't buy it.
You can't buy.
You have to pay for that with sweat,
blood and tears,
period.
And I learned also early on,
you're going to find your great leaders by following the blood trail,
literally and figuratively.
It's not hard to find.
Take off your first four blinders.
You'll find them.
Follow the blood trail.
And I knew the ones that were,
and I knew the ones that weren't.
And now so does.
Everyone else comes out in the wash.
Right?
But we,
you know,
Soi was awesome.
I mean,
I remember the first,
the first weekend that we had Lebeau
what's the first thing that you think that they tell us?
Young,
stupid marines and,
and uh,
and Soi Pendleton.
Oh,
you're getting your first liberty.
The one place not to go.
Tj,
the one place.
Let me,
where do you think like a van full of us go?
Yeah.
Did you take a Marine Corps van?
No,
but we should,
I would have been impressive.
I can't,
I still to this day,
you know,
he left Friday evening.
I to this day,
I can't be there letting me back in the United States like I was,
I was throwed hard.
And uh,
at the time my brother,
I don't know if it was his girlfriend at the time,
[inaudible] was excellent.
She was for some reason here and uh,
and so on cow.
And she was like,
Hey,
come see me.
And I saw her somewhere by the border or whatever.
I'm sure I smelled amazing.
Yeah.
And like the look on her face was like,
how are you breathing right now?
Because,
you know,
my idea was when they said turn to on liberty.
Oh yeah,
that's exactly I was,
I was seeking liberty.
Yeah,
no matter.
And I wanted to find what liberty look like.
I've told this story before I was,
we pulled into port one time I was on a ship as a seal platoon.
We pull into port and what we used to do,
there's be aligned to get off the ship,
like checking liberty cars.
So when,
uh,
when the ship into port,
we'd
work out that take an hour,
then we take a shower and then the line would be gone.
We'd go out.
So we do that.
We're,
we've been in port for like an hour and 15 minutes.
We go up to leave and they're carrying a marine back upon this shit.
He's completely covered.
A Pew passed out drunk.
He did that in like 48 minutes,
bro.
That's impressive.
It's getting after it.
Chesty will love those.
I listen.
How do you not respect that?
Because back in the day I would've been like,
I want to hang out with that.
But it's,
I mean,
that's just what,
you know,
this is what we do.
That's what that is.
What that is is an 18 year old human being that's been in bootcamp s or why
hasn't,
hasn't let loose at all and has become a man by the way,
or at least has been told in some way.
This has become a man and that's where the boot stripe,
it's like,
Bro,
you're not fooling me.
Right?
Yeah.
I get it though.
I get it man.
Because it's,
you get there and it's like,
okay,
did boot did that?
That was you know,
way more mental than physical and it's,
they're good at what they do.
Yeah,
for sure.
They're good at what they do.
I remember my grandmother telling me,
just remember they have a job to do.
They're doing their job.
Not One thing you go through is going to be personal.
She was wrong.
However,
with that one.
Yeah.
Grandma was wrong on that guy.
Same One.
And she's,
she was a hard woman,
man.
Shoes.
Um,
yeah,
she was one of those,
she used to always say I suffered from what comes up comes out syndrome because
there was no filter.
And I love that about her because it was,
it was true.
Like if she didn't like it,
you knew,
you know,
and she would always say,
as far as I'm concerned,
I have one grandbaby talking about me right in front of my siblings.
Her given f tank was bone dry,
give none.
This is the same moment.
The first time she sees me in the hospital and I'm all banged up and she says,
well baby,
I guess God didn't want you to double won't have you.
And I was like,
you know what,
I'll take it.
Me,
me.
Yeah.
I mean,
I had an old world war two marine and I was flying to Vegas for some event or
something.
Maybe I was,
I had to speak at or whatever.
And he said,
just remember young man,
bad breast by the no breath.
I said,
Roger,
that Sir were right on.
But,
um,
then it was,
you know,
boot was,
it was one of those things where you're part of the club but not like,
yeah,
you know,
you're just,
when you're an soi,
how do they figure out what position you're going to be in a platoon.
So Soi,
it's um,
it's more of a numbers thing.
Such I schooled training is oh three,
11 rifleman,
right?
And then so I go through all the o three 11 rifleman training and know you get
to,
you get to finger most of the weapons throughout the,
the infantry.
And then it was,
um,
I never understood the humps man.
I never liked him.
I always hated them because it was like,
hey,
let's go put on a stupid amount of weight.
Let's go warm up walking around motor t three or four times and look at all the
Vietnam,
all the vehicles that we're never going to use.
Like always felt like we were screwing the tax.
No,
actually I can,
I can honestly say I have never ever in my life done what you just said,
which is warm up for a hot pot.
Never done that.
I was always just like,
hey,
well I'll warm up for the first eight hours of this deal.
Well,
you know,
some real Corey Cory,
you're gonna warm up walking around the motor t.
I like that.
Yeah.
I get it to the next level.
More Mind Games is Milton Bradley Brown.
But it was,
it was the,
the humps that were like,
I was just thinking to myself like,
why don't we utilize all the stuff with motors and the rotors?
You're walking around the motor transform,
the vehicles are that could carry,
you
know,
but that was the,
you know,
that,
we finished Soi and we did you,
a lot of the training was,
um,
there were so many times where you would hear the guys cow,
we did this 10,000 times yesterday and we're doing it another 10,000 times
today.
Because as you well know,
we're all really good no matter the caliber of warrior and the amount of
training you have.
We are all class a bitchers.
Yeah,
yeah.
100%.
You guys complain about everything,
everything,
everything.
You know?
Then we'd go off to these foreign places and these gnarly situations and we get
home and we're like,
I want to go back to that.
And I said,
I know why that is the way it is now.
I know now.
And that's just because as crazy as it is,
it's easier.
Oh yeah.
Well you got to have some fun with it.
Yeah.
Will you come back here?
And it's like,
it's just fricking Jerry Springer and the Kardashians,
like just,
and it's like when can we just utilize an ounce of common sense,
you know,
just please for the love of God and all the totally,
could we just call a dog a dog and a cat,
a cat and a man.
Be a man and a woman.
Be a woman and not worry about everything in between and all the judgment that's
going to follow being what God made you like.
Could we just focus on toughening up and teaching our children who will one day
lead this country that,
believe it or not,
the planet doesn't give a shit about your feelings.
You're not always going to win.
Then Mommy and daddy are not always going to be there.
Definitely new with the rotor wash from the helicopter.
Like that's going to go away jack cause this world a little punch you in the
mouth and then the laugh,
what do we teach our kids?
One of the,
my son knows,
cause I tell him,
it is my job as your parent to make sure you were prepared to take said punch
and punch back because at some point it's going to happen.
And I would rather you lose,
rather you're,
you're in an MMA competition or baseball or whatever it is.
I would rather you lose doing everything properly at a 100% then when not doing
the fundamentals of the way you're supposed to and going 50%
and he looked at me like,
well dad didn't know.
Believe it or not,
it's not always about winning because you're going to lose a lot.
Yeah,
it's a life.
Yeah.
And I mean it's,
it's,
it's something that's just start young,
start young,
letting them know that it's not all rainbows,
roses and lollipop's,
that there's no such thing as waking up on your Unicorn Ranch and picking which
Unicorn you're going to ride on,
what rainbow to wherever you go.
It doesn't exist.
Can you do me a favor?
Can you just that last part about no UNICORNS.
Can you not tell my daughter that my eight year old daughter and she's like,
yeah,
she thinks that he's
setting traps and going imagine that.
Hey,
so you had done with Soi.
Yeah.
And now and now,
where do you go?
So you are you in the reserves at this time?
Yeah.
So at the I get don't the Soi and I go check in and uh,
I was late.
No,
that's good.
Call checking in.
Yeah.
So I didn't,
it was a communication breakdown,
right?
Sure.
So I didn't,
it wasn't my fault.
No,
nothing was hell.
This recruit just don't know sir.
But it was a,
a situation the guy checked in with was,
where were you checking it?
W W what were you checking into?
My unit and it was in Basia also known as bowser.
Yeah.
So I was supposed to check in with a dude that I was in a boot or soi with.
I can't remember.
We went to booth together or not,
but uh,
he goes and checks in,
I believe it was a Friday.
And so he goes and checks on Friday,
the first sergeant and then he calls me,
he's like,
Jake first started no where the hell you are.
And I was like,
dude,
I thought
you're,
he said,
no bro,
he won't see like now.
So I'm there Monday morning,
first thing he looks at me and he was like,
well,
that whole worried though dog.
I was like,
uh,
sorry for sure.
And uh,
you know,
so,
so it didn't tell me that it,
he was like,
I see you keep her.
And I was like,
there's no easy way out of this.
You know,
I look around is his office and all of his awards and the accolades.
And I'm just like,
I just asked him like,
do you,
can we just go to the gym when you beat shamine just get,
let's get this over with.
And I saw all those things where you were when your dad asks you like,
not do you want to be grounded for a moth or do you want the belt?
10 Times out of 10,
I'm like,
you want me to go get the belt for you?
Cause that's easier.
Right?
Let's just,
let's just get through the temporary pain and then move forward and with,
I was the same with first,
sorry,
which I think in the beginning he liked,
you know,
it's a little beginning.
Yeah.
Because it was,
I developed a bit of repetition over time,
but it was,
um,
again,
liberty,
but he was,
um,
little did I know that I was checking in with now sergeant major of the Marine
Corps.
Oh Damn.
And I didn't,
I had,
of course,
you know,
you can't present a future shout on that.
Yeah.
And so it was,
but he was the one,
one of the guys who's,
he's just a marine's marine man.
He's,
he's like you,
you know,
it's like he,
he fell off a poster and there he was,
you know,
like three red stripe,
big matte black belt.
I mean drillmaster all,
you name it.
And he did it.
And so he,
uh,
we got pretty tight and you know,
he,
he disciplined me when he had to,
but it was one of those things where at the time my unit when I checked in was
actually in get mo and they were doing base security and all that stuff.
And then they,
uh,
he tells me,
hey,
stay close to your phone.
You're going to go meet up with your unit and get well.
Am I get a Roger that first?
Sorry,
are we in 2002 yet?
This is,
yeah.
So this is a x,
I was in boot deer and
marine corp birthday and Christmas.
And so this was a
flashback to being in bootcamp for the Marine Corp Birthday and Christmas Marine
Corps Birthday.
I don't know if they still do it.
I'm sure they do.
Oh yeah.
But they give you steak and shrimp and like cake in the Chow Hall.
So we got back to the barracks and that one day I was telling you about who I
pray to.
God,
here's this cause he's,
he'll know exactly what I am.
Come find me Bro.
And uh,
but we line up,
we'd get online in the squad bay and he makes us,
we're,
we just finished this epic mill.
We had more than like a minute and a half to eat.
Got to sit there for a good five or six minutes,
which is an eternity at the time we get back online and start pounding canteens.
Hold them up.
You ever had run back to the hood,
refill them,
get back online,
found the canteens,
hold them over your head.
Empty.
Do again and again and again.
And he said,
we're doing this until every one of you pukes up that mill that you don't
deserve.
Yay.
And so,
um,
and we did.
And then the first of course,
chain reaction,
the first few kicks.
And then that just starts like with me,
I would rather seriously be,
have like cruel and unusual punishment done to me than puke.
So I'm fighting it like,
like a Mo,
like I'm fighting it hard.
And then the company CEO walks in the back door and it was hilarious because the
said the I like goes white like Oh yeah,
cause he's hazing,
you know?
And that's when daddy walks in and sees it.
Just walked by all of us.
And he's like,
he had to go back behind this,
the racks because he didn't want to get puke on is us against,
you're just puking on the deck right in the middle school.
So yeah,
it was all,
oh yeah.
Cause we were just going to duck tail it after the fact anyway.
But then that was,
that was Marine Corps boot that was um,
I'm sorry,
uh,
marine corps birthday.
So then Christmas rolls around,
same Dai and uh,
it's Christmas Eve,
you know,
we do our lights out and I th chesty wherever you are,
he opens the door and we'll just say it was like Rudolph the red nose reindeer.
Everyone knows the song,
right?
So he opens the door to the duty hut and all you hear is Rudolph the red Bam,
the door slam.
And you just hear him go,
that's all you get pitches.
So you hear a lot of these one liners that I got,
I stayed in trouble in the Marine Corps for laughing when you're not supposed to
lie like fat to laugh,
it's common.
I can't hold it,
I immediately lose it.
But one of the guys who was already in the targets of the Dei,
I started laughing and it was,
I think he was gone like a Dan half layer.
Like it was.
Yeah,
but it just,
some of these one liners,
man,
it's like you hear him,
it's like where did these dudes come up with this stuff?
But then you see him yelling at trees on the,
on the base and they were like,
oh,
like they're graded on yelling at a tree who wakes up.
Like I wanted to do that one wasn't me.
But I,
I checked in the dude's wearing get mo and um,
I stayed by my phone.
Phone never rang.
So I got,
I was,
I lucked out.
What were you doing in the civilian?
I said where you live in as a,
so I started school drill one weekend a month or whatever.
I started school.
I,
yeah,
I mean,
and I was training,
you know,
getting ready to,
cause I knew we were going to go in Iraq or Afghanistan,
just didn't know which one,
you know,
it was being in align unit.
You knew we were going to go.
And so it was um,
the guys got home and we started training and uh,
I'm in school,
which went about like high school,
went and minus the football
and then a honors student.
So you're really hears,
it was funny because
I realized early on like,
I can do this,
I can do the school thing.
Huh.
The only downfall to that was,
is it was like,
okay,
I've have been after this for a year.
I've already proved myself I can do this.
I don't need to see it through,
but it's now I'm just wasting my time.
You know,
there's a lot of beer to drink and you know,
typical mindset.
But the,
but my unit gets home and I go and meet the guys,
which is like every other you show up to the first time.
It's like going to jail the first time.
Like you're immediately being sized up.
And it's like,
but I was one of those guys who like,
I was not,
I just wasn't going to take your shit.
And so it went well for me because I was able to use dumps,
shrinks and humor to kind of get in with the,
with the guys who outranked me.
And uh,
but they also knew that I,
I love that.
I love what I did.
And so the guys get back and this one guy who's a freaking mortar men go figure
and he's like,
Hey Schick,
you're a big dude.
You should be a gunner.
You're going to be governor.
What do you think about being a gunner?
Well,
it doesn't matter.
You're going to be a gunner.
So I was like,
all right,
whatever.
So like 31,
okay,
go be a gunner.
And uh,
then we did our first hump with that system.
I like that.
And I was like,
I'm going to beat that dude within an inch of his life.
Cause I knew I could.
And I was like,
that son of a bitch should not tell me that th that came with like a tripod and
then it was like,
ah,
sucked.
But it was,
you know,
I mean,
you're earning your stripes,
you know.
But it was one of those things where we,
we were just waiting,
but we were a tight unit.
We were a tight knit group.
And I think,
I think that probably had a lot to do with us knowing that it's a matter of
time.
Right,
right.
And most of us weren't prior combat guys when we were young unit.
And um,
it was interesting man,
because it was,
it was a,
it was an eclectic group and a group,
a group from all walks of life,
which is something that I always really admired about the military regardless of
what branch or special whatever is that you are forced to communicate and to
adapt with other people because if you don't,
you're,
you're screwed.
Yeah.
And that's something that I always appreciated.
And at the same time at warned me the hell out because there was some guy,
you know there's,
there's some guys that you're just like,
Yo,
if I never saw that guy again,
it'd be too soon.
And it's usually just because,
you know it's,
well I always have to explain to civilians that I'm working with,
cause a lot of people have the impression of civilians that uh,
you know,
the civilians have the impression that everyone in the military is just like a
machine that just is going to do what they're told.
And if you're the sergeant,
the Corp was going to listen to you and it's like,
well I'm not currently,
doesn't like that.
Like it'll work like that for a little while and worked for a little while.
But over time those,
those,
those young guys will,
or the junior people,
if you're not leading them correctly,
you're not going to have to get things done.
Oh,
you can turn into a shit show real quick,
real quick,
real quick.
Because you're also dealing with a bunch of dudes that feel like that,
that are of the mindset I can take on this world,
have one hand tied behind my back by myself.
You're dealing with that,
you know exactly what I'm talking about.
Those Alpha personalities are abundant.
Yeah.
And then you mix in a lot of testosterone is stupidity and you have a very
dangerous situation.
Low Iq,
high tea counts.
That's basically what it is,
is it is.
But um,
now did you guys,
did you guys do like the,
so you're doing one weekend,
a month,
a drill and then you do two weeks in the summertime,
but then in what,
2003 you guys would call it per 2004,
I think we got,
we got the call and it'll three I believe,
if I'm not mistaken,
I've been blown up since then and hit in the head a lot.
So I don't know.
I think we got the call and no three saying that we were going to be called at a
certain time and it gave you like a warning order.
Like okay,
it's common pretty much.
And then they said,
okay,
you're going to go do your work up and a 29 palms,
California.
And so we,
you know,
we get to 29 palms.
And I was like,
I remember man,
getting off that burden.
I was just like,
this place sucks.
I thought you were going to have something really profound to say no.
And you said it took 29 palms this place.
It was,
I was like,
why?
Why do?
Of course the marines would have this base.
Of course it made total sense.
You know,
it was just like,
let the bitching begin.
It was abundant,
bro.
It was abundant because unless you had money to go to palm springs,
I'll see you at 29 stops,
run out to get stuff and we are inevitably going to be fighting.
This is the amazing thing.
This is the amazing thing is
I get asked or I got to ask on the podcast,
you know,
how do,
how do I,
you know,
my,
I,
I checked into a battalion or I think the guy was a company commander.
That morale morale's not good.
How do we get them all good?
Like do hard things.
You want to improve morale,
do hard things.
And one of the things like what are you going to do at 29 stumps we can do
there?
Well,
you're going to hang out with each other.
That's what you're gonna do.
It's gonna suck.
You're gonna want to feel to go to sweats,
going to be hot and you can do hard things and you're going to become tighter as
a unit.
That's what happens.
Yeah.
Imagine that.
Weird,
weird,
it's just weird how that works now.
Who was running the training?
They have a training cadre out there.
So we,
uh,
I'm trying to remember.
It was,
um,
or are you guys training yourselves or use your,
is your officer leading
the trail?
Donny.
Sergeant,
yeah.
I mean we,
we had gunny,
there was kind of both,
right?
We had like,
we would go to mount town or whatever.
We would have some mountains truckers out there,
but it wasn't because,
I mean a lot of guys were forward deployed.
Yeah.
I mean were gone and,
but we,
we literally,
we trained,
we trained hard.
I mean it was,
you talk about training for the sake of muscle memory.
We,
it was gnarly what we did and it was a,
like he said,
we did a lot of hard things too.
Then we only got tighter and tighter and tighter as a unit,
but we,
it was a,
I mean I remember the first time we went out to do our first training evolution
out at American minds and we,
we hopped out there of course,
because you don't want to use the vehicles.
And uh,
I remember we staged,
we stage our gear and my platoon sergeant drops us pack and there's like a,
like a little rattlesnake den by where he dropped his pack.
And so we had to go move and then he goes to put his pack on the move and
there's a black score Scorpio on his pack.
And I was like,
this is awesome.
Like this is,
and then we had a ton of bees that were go after the,
the,
the water buffalo and of the trailer,
the water trailers and it was like,
we can't,
yeah,
it's just,
it's inevitable.
Marine Corps Shit.
Like it's the suck factor is going to be pegged the entire time.
Yeah.
And it was just,
it's,
it's like this guy was just looking down on us,
man.
Like,
Hey,
you're going to earn it
one day.
I'm going to have this uh,
team guy,
buddy of mine.
He's got a lot of rattlesnakes,
Norris from the desert because rattlesnakes are very amusing.
You know,
once you start catching them and putting them in people's vehicles and putting
them in there,
they're back,
pastor.
Just stuff like that.
Like,
yeah.
That's cool.
I'm telling you right now,
I'm not kidding.
We want to see someone jump though.
Yeah,
it does.
But Hey,
you know,
they don't know that the fangs had been removed.
Rip The thanks Allen.
The leatherman asked me how much I care.
You completely missing the point.
It's the principle snake season.
Get some
dude.
It was the,
some of the best.
The Dark Greens did do not like the,
the little creatures and the creepy crawlies and seeing some of the reactions of
some of the dark greens was,
what's the dark greens.
They're there to be politically correct.
They're African American.
Got Dark Green Marines,
Gotcha.
Calm,
dark
greens.
And they know and they call him.
So it's accepted,
right?
It doesn't bother him.
Doug Greene,
they don't write their congressman.
It's unbelievable the way that works.
So they're there.
It's y'all.
And I got to see one,
I just spoke to this a deal a couple days ago and that was yesterday.
And one of the marines I served was there,
his dark green and a man.
It was all,
it was pride and seen him in a decade.
Didn't miss a beat.
It was,
it was like seriously didn't miss a beat.
And I'm like,
man,
that was God.
Just imagine,
imagine if mankind could have a taste of that just to taste.
It would be,
imagine how much better the spinning ball chaos would be.
But it's,
it was awesome.
It was just good to see him and,
and to see the way that he changed.
You just see the maturity over time.
You know,
the of,
of how life can,
it alters your course and alters your mindset because of the things you
experienced and you go through and in the how many times you're taught how human
you are,
you know,
it was,
it was cool.
It was good for the soul,
you know,
and uh,
yeah,
it was just cool to see him and be able to embrace that dude.
And I mean that's my family.
That is,
I don't give a shit what color skin is.
That dude's my blood and that's just the way it is.
That's the way it always will be.
But we,
um,
and he used to,
he used to annoy the shit out of me.
Like I used to thought of think like his,
his mouth is never going to shut like one of these days,
man,
one of these days.
And uh,
but it was so epic cause it was like,
that's my bro,
you know?
And it was,
it was just awesome,
man.
It just goes to show you,
like we get these little reminders in life if,
if you just shut your mouth and listen,
you get these little reminders of how worth it everything's been and what
purpose everything is served.
And it was cool to see you that I got one of those,
you know,
and it gives me,
it was a little fuel for the soul to it to keep going.
But um,
I remember this,
our first loss was in uh,
March air force base.
We were doing how satisfying and abandoned housing unit in March Air Force Base.
And it was,
um,
it was a training laws cause if we guy that they were practicing j turns in a
Humvee and uh,
there's a young kid,
he wasn't our company,
he was a different company,
same battalion and the,
the Humvee flipped.
And he was just the inertia of the Humvee flipping.
He couldn't get out of the Turret and uh,
it was up armored.
And so when it flips,
it obviously kills the gunner.
There's no way he's going to get out.
And so mandatory 24 hour safety,
stand down,
let's take our phones.
And all that stuff and you know,
hey,
don't ride home.
Don't call anyone.
This is,
we got to abide by the Sop.
That was,
uh,
you know,
that was one of an eye opening deal man.
That was like,
okay,
this is the real deal.
Like this.
We're not,
this is the life and death game we're playing.
And I'll never forget when we got back to 29 palms,
which I don't remember if it was a couple of days later,
three days later,
a day later,
whatever.
But we wake up and we go to formation and we walk out to go to formation and um,
men,
everywhere you looked,
you saw a piece of computer paper,
just a regular piece of paper,
turn horizontally.
They were taped all over the place.
Everywhere you looked.
And all he said on him was complacency kills.
Everywhere you look,
you saw that complacency kills gunny.
It just printed out all these papers and that to this day,
that sticks with me.
And I think about it,
not every,
all the time because we all get complacent,
but it could not be more true.
Whether it's literal,
you know,
or figuratively speaking.
I mean you,
and of course in most of our lives nowadays,
you get complacent.
Yeah.
You might not die,
but something can be irreversibly damaged.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I talk about that all the time.
They just get complacent.
Even the complacency on the little things in life that's just putting you down
the wrong path where that's just the way it is.
That's the reality.
Hey Man,
let me tell you that
I could be referred to as captain complacent when it comes to that.
I'll be the first to tell you that I'm much more centered than saying,
I always say,
you know that God gave his only son to suffer and down across as he knew there
was going to be guys like me.
The only differences is I'm willing to admit it.
You know,
I'm on my floor.
Then I say all the time that I've stood with everything from leaders of mankind,
the presidents to the most savage individuals you'll ever meet and everything in
between.
The one common denominator is every one of them is equally fundamentally flawed.
Every single one and no doubt about that and they just have different clothes
on.
That's it.
That's what I'm saying,
man.
If we could stop,
if we could just stop with this political correctness in this
false manufactured protection
we could keep,
I always say if we,
if you took out self interest and self gain and the fight for the greater good,
imagine where we would be right now.
Imagine where we would be because we would be leaps and bounds ahead of where we
are.
We'd be light years ahead of where we are if there was nothing to be gained to
help someone that you've never met and they can never repay you.
You just do it because we've been so conditioned to be selfish and it's
unfortunate because that's what I love about this guy was a gift for all
intensive purposes.
The Godfather,
the Marine Corps,
and people can say how he may have been arrogant or pompous or whatever,
but I guarantee you he was the last one to eat.
Oh yeah,
he was definitely the last one to eat.
And actually that book's a great book and there's a,
there's a,
there's a diff big difference between his reputation of what people thought
about him that never worked with them.
People that worked with him,
the soul,
the marines that work with them,
that served with him,
that he would go around their foxholes at night in negative 25 degree weather in
and,
and ask guys if they're okay and give him,
give him a shot of whiskey.
I mean,
he,
they loved him because he cared about those.
He cared about them.
That's the,
the image.
As a matter of fact,
like he had this driver that was with him for a long time.
Jones was his last name and [inaudible] Jones.
People would come up and say,
how did you stay with chesty puller for so long?
Didn't eat,
chew you out and demote you.
And he's like,
no,
the guy never yelled at me ever.
That's,
that's the difference.
That's the difference between,
that's the dichotomy between what this image was and what he was really like.
The people who he would,
the reason he had a reputation for being,
you know,
super,
uh,
I guess I guess direct with people was a way he went up the chain of command
when he would tell an admiral out on a ship,
like,
you better put those bombs where we need them right now.
Or you know,
he up the chain of command or he'd come back to America and say,
Hey,
the,
the binoculars that you're building suck.
And they,
and they steam up.
We can't see anything.
What's wrong with you?
So that's where he got the reputation.
But down the chain of command,
he was not like that.
There's another great story in there that cover on the podcast where he catches
a guy sleeping.
I'll watch there and training and he wakes the guy up and he's the battalion
commander.
He wakes the guy up and he says,
Hey,
what are you doing sleeping?
One of your captain would have caught you.
He would've,
he would have had me come to court martial you had been a disaster.
You've got to stay awake.
Old Man.
That's his nickname for everyone was old man.
But that's the difference is he cared.
He cared so much about as men and,
and you know,
that's the,
that's the incredibly hard part that we were talking about earlier.
It's like when he's,
when his son comes home from Vietnam and you know,
he's like,
his heart is broken,
it's broken and he can't even speak and he can't,
he's just convulsing with tears.
And it's because,
you know,
he loved his son,
but his son was representative of every marine and he said that,
you know,
he said that it was like the,
that the closing that book.
And he tells his wife,
his wife says,
what do you want to do now that it's all over?
And he's like,
I want to see the face of every marine I ever served.
Dude.
You know,
I mean that right there in it for anyone who's listening to this and questioning
what is my purpose?
Why am I,
why am I alive?
Why am I here?
What's the point to things?
And it's the same for every individual.
No matter what country,
no matter what little village,
doesn't matter.
We all have our here to do two things,
love and be loved.
That's it.
Everything else is filler love and be loved.
It's hard as shit because we make it harder.
Shit.
That's it.
When he saw his son,
that all came crashing down on them.
That's reality.
Yeah.
It was one of those
liking,
rather it was in Lewis's situation where when you're severely wounded or you
lose someone that you love tremendously.
I mean with reckless abandonment,
you,
you love all the way and if you're of the right warrior mindset or first
responder law enforcement and you've been around that and you're,
you're the real deal,
you're probably just like me or you or you're incapable of loving halfway.
They're incapable of it because if we did that,
we're taking away from that in which we're supposed to be true to it to honor.
And that's,
that's the point.
It's you get,
you don't get a piece of humble pie you and held the factory all at once
and that's just what it is.
And some guys don't come out of that,
you know?
And if I'm,
if I wasn't surrounded by people that were better than me and that refused to
love me to death,
okay,
I would be loose
and far be it for me to sit here and look at you and say not an option.
It's not an option.
Because one thing I've learned in this fight,
this fight of mental health and of this floating noodle in between our ears is
that no one gets a pass.
Nobody gets a pass.
I don't care who you are,
what you've been through,
what you know,
who you know,
you don't get a pass.
And I've learned that the hard way from having to bury friends over and over and
over and over
and to talk myself out of,
you're not worth it.
It would be easier for them if you weren't here
and letting the demons get the better of me.
Like it's a constant dance.
Like when people say,
Oh,
well you know Jake Friday,
a lot of pressure off.
You just work on your,
your,
your work and life balance.
I think because it's,
you just got to find your balance.
Well,
okay,
here's some news.
There is no balance.
It's a constant dance.
You're constantly trying to figure it out.
It's just like our enemies in Iraq,
Afghanistan,
it's,
we changed our tactics.
They change theirs,
we change ours,
they changed theirs.
We change ours.
It's a constant dance.
It's never finite,
right?
Nothing is.
That's one of the things that makes life worth living.
I don't want to wake up tomorrow and know what tomorrow has in store for me.
What's the point?
I just want to wake up and love and be loved
all the way.
Not Halfway be hotter,
be cold.
If you're lukewarm,
get the hell out of my foxhole.
I don't want to fight with you.
Let's talk about when you went on deployment now.
So it's 2004 is when you deploy it like the summer of 2004.
Yeah.
And where do you guys deploy to?
So we are primary io was the Sunni Triangle,
the barrack beautiful,
beautiful place.
We landed in Kuwait.
We were only in Kuwait,
I think they called it camp victory.
Maybe.
I can't remember the name of it.
It was before the pizza huts and subways and all that.
I know that for a fact
what we go,
we landed Kuwait.
We were only there for a couple of days.
And um,
we get on the bird and I'll never forget this.
We were on the,
on the tarmac and Kuwait getting ready to flow over al-assad.
And um,
I think,
I believe if I'm not mistaken,
it was,
I think we,
we were on the first three c one thirties we got on,
we had to get off of,
cause they weren't mechanically sound or or whatever
or just gun.
He just felt like strong with us.
Who knows?
But we had to get off of him,
but it wasn't gunny,
cause I remember the fourth one and we're all sweating our asses off August.
It's miserable.
Miserable.
And I remember the fourth one,
I don't know if it was the crew chief of the load master,
whoever,
but gunny took some someone somewhere and I'm pretty sure it was a conversation
pretty much like if this bird didn't take off,
you're not going to go home alive anyway.
It cause it sucked.
I mean,
we were all in me.
We have everything on.
Yeah.
You know,
and were
frontline marine.
So we
were geared out and it's with stuff we'll never use ever.
But it was on the gear list.
Got Abbott.
Yeah.
And so we,
but we ended up landing in outside.
And I remember when we get off the bird now was,
and I thought to myself,
man,
29 balls on it.
Well now that I'm Asada do that two year,
I miss it already,
you know.
And,
um,
so we,
we get off and we go to our,
our tent where we're sleeping with our bunk beds and,
um,
we started the,
the brief the next day and I remember we were,
is that where you guys were going to be working out of where you guys actually
going to be camp at?
Stationed at all Assad primarily,
yeah.
But I mean rarely got this stay that's where your headquarters were.
Yeah,
it was [inaudible] battalion was,
okay.
So we start the,
the 48 hour brief
and we're in the middle of that and um,
captain walks in,
we're in one of the hangars and you get a look on his face that,
you know,
something wasn't good obviously.
And it was because during the left seat,
right seat of the unit we were placing got hit and they lost,
I don't want to misquote it,
but I'm,
one of the guys I was just with this past weekend was there,
um,
in that unit we replaced two,
seven,
and it was a,
they had lost like a,
like an Xo.
The first sergeant,
like it was bad.
They guess from a [inaudible] was an IED strike.
I,
yeah,
it was,
um,
id with attraction.
They,
it was just a bad situation after action.
So they took fire and it was not like,
it wasn't an isolated event.
They hit the lady goes,
and then when they find your one hit with RPGs,
there's a,
it was,
it was a gnarly situation.
They shouldn't have been in because it happened in a police that was,
yeah.
Friendly.
And,
um,
and at the time,
actually when we were over there,
I don't even,
I think we still call them roadside bomb.
I don't even think we called them ids yet.
I don't think we utilize that terminology yet,
if I'm not mistaken.
And again,
I could be wrong.
It's happened before,
but we,
so we hear this and it,
I mean,
it's just like,
we're like,
oh shit,
that's not good.
Oh,
that stuff's not supposed to happen.
And um,
so that was another big awakening moment.
Right.
And,
but we get ready to,
to leave.
And,
um,
at this time I'm,
I'm a machine gun team leader.
Little that I know I'd become leader of the react team.
Seems Qrf Quick Reaction Force.
And
so we,
we have like the 16 vehicle convoy or something,
which would be a huge no,
no nowadays.
And I remember the Sir walk by and he was like,
Hey Schick,
we need when you someone a man that pig on the lead vehicle and you're going to
get bought in at two 40 on the lead vehicle.
And I was like,
who's going to jump on that pig?
And we were just in briefs hearing about Guidewire's they'd put Guidewire's
across the road trying to decapitate gunners.
Yeah.
I had left my first deployment and uh,
I want to say April or May of 2004 so it was Romney right before.
Yeah.
So,
and I was just trying to think if we were using the term id and I'm almost
positive we work cause I remember,
I remember,
but you guys are special.
Yeah,
no,
I know but I was trying to think.
I remember like I,
I'm,
I'm actually be envisioning a slide.
We caught an IED maker and,
and we had all this,
like he had wires and he had,
uh,
like clocks,
multiple clocks from,
uh,
from like,
timers like kitchen timers.
And he said,
we had wires,
kitchen timers,
all this stuff.
And they're like,
hey,
this guy you caught,
he's an innocent guy.
And I was like,
well,
no.
And they say,
well,
no,
he's innocent.
What evidence do you have?
And I,
I brought these pictures and I'm like,
look at this stuff that we took off this target.
It's all IED stuff.
And they were like,
oh,
okay.
But it was the first,
it was kind of first starting to assemble the idea that people were building
these improvised explosive device.
So I think we were using it.
But you're right.
Might not a spread to the Marine Corps yet.
At this point.
We're kind of slow,
but we're Dudley,
I don't,
we might have,
you know,
that was a long time ago.
That's a relevant cause.
Roadside bombs,
that wasn't good enough.
It's called an night.
Well,
if it's not,
if you don't have,
don't the church don't charge it up.
So what we,
but we're,
we're out there.
We have our convoy and um,
so I asked the guys,
right,
okay,
who's going to go man,
that pig and it's crickets.
I was like,
oh,
very well.
I got it.
I looked at him and say,
Hey sir,
I got it.
I'm going to do it.
And then of course I know,
okay,
no.
I'm like,
If,
phew,
phew.
When I die.
You just remember what you let her niece to say
cause you were of a Jj and uh,
we'll see a lot,
a lot more colorful language.
But I jumped up there man.
And it was
look,
pucker,
factor pegged,
you know,
pegged
like how do you see guidewire?
But can you see the guidewire?
Does the sun have to be hit in a certain way?
Like what is,
what am I looking for?
You know,
you have armored Humvees.
No,
most of them weren't.
Yeah.
And do you know,
did the most of them are two door soft tops?
Yeah.
Get something.
That's where we had the turret.
Where's the turret?
Six
vehicles.
The six thoughts better isn't comfortable.
I mean,
I'd rather be in that than a Humvee.
If I'm in the lead vehicle,
I would rather be in a harrier.
Okay.
But it was,
but we,
that's why you signed up for an infantry gets us right and we hate it.
And you know,
the pilots,
it was like there are a bunch of Prima donnas and we'd see him come in and land
and go to their air condition cans and then we're like,
you know,
they're eating steak and shrimp.
You know,
they're,
they're all comfortable and they're in there on their sleep number bed.
You know,
you make all this stuff up in your head.
I'll tell you what,
you made that up in your head.
We had a,
we had a World War II pilot on here,
Jim Kunkel.
And he was literally saying like,
hey though the war in Europe for me,
he was a p 38 pilot.
He's like,
my missions are reckoned it like 45 minutes.
they're always backing.
I was back at base now of course that was 45 minutes.
We're pretty sketchy.
You ended up getting shot down.
But uh,
you know,
a lot of missions that he did is exactly what you said,
that that's the reality of being a pilot.
That's the reality of it.
You know,
and then,
but until you need them.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
of course the first time that happens you're like,
oh yeah,
we need those guys ever.
Sure.
But it's his stream because there's a,
there's a line guy,
you know,
it was a grunt.
I mean you're trained from day one.
Every other job in the United States military is to support you.
That's true.
You know,
you're trained that which I'm not,
I,
I mean I won't say if I agree or disagree with it now because it's like I tell
civilians like,
think of the,
of the military is a giant will with a lot of spokes.
Combat guys are like a super small portion of one spoke.
Yeah.
It takes a lot of moving parts to make this machine turn.
That's true.
And so it's true.
It's rather it's in support.
Like,
listen,
I'm over that I don't need,
I don't need that anymore.
Like,
I understand why guys think that.
I understand the mindset.
There's a,
there's a great,
I was listening to some Hackworth talking Colonel David Hackworth and one of the
things that he said,
he was trying to explain how many people were in combat in Vietnam in combat.
And it was like 10% of the troops.
So at the peak of Vietnam there was 560,000 people in country in Vietnam and
like 50,000 of them were actually engaged in combat at that at any one time.
And that's probably a pretty good figure.
A lot of the World War One and world to World War II statistics are the same.
It's like 10 to one.
There's 10 support people for every one person that's going to like close,
close with and destroy the enemy,
you know,
it's the way it is.
Yeah.
And I mean it's,
I would never look at a supply guy or of course when I was in,
I did it all the time.
I'm like a pug don't chose told you bait or whatever.
The stupid shit is what you say.
But I see him now and it's like,
hey man,
I appreciate you sir.
It's like,
oh well I could,
I didn't do anything and I'm a k first of all there is no Richter skill on pain
and suffering.
You know what makes it unique is that it's unique to the individual.
You can't grade it.
So like your,
you know,
your sprained ankle when you were,
you roll your ankle playing basketball during your lunch hour.
How do you know that didn't hurt as bad?
Is My fibula and Tibia coming out of my left leg?
It might've,
I'm going to question you a little bit on that one.
But the point that we get talking about this support people in the military,
they do a great job.
Then we wouldn't,
the frontline troops wouldn't be able to do anything without them.
So that's what I say.
And vice versa.
If the frontline troops weren't there,
the sport people would have no job.
That's the attitude I always had.
And we were a team that had any cover move together.
And if the Intel people didn't supply the Intel and if the CVS didn't build the
bases and keep the generator's running and the combat engineers weren't out
clear.
I mean it's like it takes a truck.
Exactly.
And so that's my point.
And it's like,
listen,
if you're still in and you're a non combat role,
be proud of what you're doing.
Yeah,
no,
try it out.
You know,
I have guys that I meet now and they say,
well I was in from,
you know,
84 to 90 and I never did anything.
And I was like,
Hey,
you did what your country asks you to do.
Yeah.
You know,
I stopped with that mindset,
man.
You've been conditioned
just to call it what it is by guys like I used to be to believe you didn't do
anything.
Okay.
Well the more mature me still pretty dumb,
but the more mature me is here to tell you thank you for carrying the flag
before I did.
Yeah.
That's another point is like who is going to train you?
Who,
who's the Deis to put you through boot camp and who's the guys that trained them
in 1984.
Right.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
it's a long chain.
It's the gift that keeps on giving,
you know,
and it's,
but
you served,
you're doing more than most.
You know,
Be Proud of that fact.
And so,
but I,
but I remember being w we,
we leave the wire for the first time analysis.
And,
um,
so we had guys drive in the six ton that were motor t guys that weren't our
guys.
So I didn't know him and we,
it was like a,
I don't know if he's like a lance Cooley and then there was a staff sergeant and
the driver's seat and I'm up on the tour.
Right.
And so I'm just like,
all right,
well,
you know,
whatever.
And so we're coming,
we come out of the gate
and we bang a left and we're headed to our first checkpoint,
which by the way,
the Iraqi national guard.
And I reckon police knew what would our checkpoints where when we were leaving,
when we were going to get there.
So that's awesome.
Yeah,
because you know,
there's some really smart people in DC that thought that was a good idea.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah,
so that obviously that,
that standard operating procedure didn't last real long because we've,
we knew it was a bad idea and,
but you know,
where it had to get back to them,
like,
hey,
bombs and stuff like just follow us everywhere we go.
It's weird.
It's almost like they know we're going to be there.
Imagine that,
you know?
And so I remember,
I'm like,
it took some type of contact,
right?
I'm lead vehicle and the dude and the DRI,
the driver stops on a,
in the middle of a bridge.
And I distinctly remember in training,
do not stop on a bridge.
And so I'm telling us,
dude,
like get off the bridge and he's like looking at a staff sergeant German saloon.
Like he's yelling at me.
And so I start kicked guys kicking him in his home,
but like get off the Prayaj and staff sort of didn't news.
That's where I was like,
dude,
just get off the bridge.
[inaudible] sounds like a good idea.
Yeah.
And so it was a chick core push.
We got off the bridge and I'm like,
hey genius.
How do you know that that thing wasn't going to blow?
Don't stop on a bridge ever.
Your motor t I'm just shocked that someone didn't tell you don't stop on a
bridge cause you're,
you're a sitting duck.
And it's like w that was my like welcome ty rag moment when it was,
um,
and man,
we just started everything after that pretty much,
pretty much just blurs together until the day that we got told that we were
going to go to do lab,
which was for all intensive purposes,
an Ammo dump was pretty much with Doula was,
and that's where we were.
The insurgents were going to get unexploded ordinance and I mean thousands and
thousands and thousands of Rpgs Ek's 7.62 rounds,
mortars,
I mean thousands.
And we had to combat engineers out there all day,
every day,
blowing stuff.
I mean,
they just couldn't blow it quick enough because we would find so many of these
weapon cache.
It's everywhere.
It was insane.
And so,
but we go through,
we get to up to the point of know it gets,
it's a little after a moth that were there and we get
the order that we're going to go to do lab,
which for most of us was like,
okay,
we can breathe some kickback time,
relax.
I had a bad feeling about it right in my gut.
As soon as they told us I heard Doula and I knew it was our turn to go and
secure the perimeter Doula.
I had a,
I got a bad feeling in my gut,
but know what it was.
And so my role was when I left,
when I left
the states and I told my family,
hey listen,
here's the deal.
Don't send me anything.
Don't write me.
I'm not gonna write.
You.
Don't watch the news.
And no news is good news.
I'll see you in seven months.
Because in my mind,
I had a job to do and I didn't need them in my head with their first world
bullshit.
And because my family puts the jury in sprayer and so definitely didn't need
that.
And so that was my mindset.
But I,
we get,
we were told we're going to do lab and so I get this weird feeling in my gut and
I'm like,
dad,
why don't know what that is.
It's the night before we head out and get a shower and a hot shower and I'm
walking back to our tit from the shower trailer and I'll walk by gunny and
gunny,
he was assaulted gunny man.
He,
I mean he was like a,
like a 23 year gunny that he earned it.
And uh,
and I loved them.
Everybody loved them,
you know,
and he was one of those guys where if you tell them good morning and then he
doesn't tell you,
like if he,
if he don't,
if you don't hear something back,
like go ask your mom.
If you hear like good morning back gun,
he's pissed about something and it's going to be a long day.
Like if you were like go after her mom,
you're like sweets gun,
he's in a good mood.
He's just,
he was that guy,
you know,
and um,
everybody loved him.
Everybody respected him because he demanded it.
Andy commanded because he would be the first guy.
If it pops off,
he's going to be right there.
He's not,
he's not ducking behind anything.
He's the dude walking up and down the line smoking a cigar.
That's that gunny.
He's that guy.
And it was just an abundant amount of respect to you that,
and
even if even if you hated them,
you love to hate them,
you know?
But I love the dude because it was for me,
he was what the Marine Corps meant
as one individual.
And I dug that about him.
I was like,
that's,
I need to be around him all the time.
I want more of what's in his head in mind.
I can learn a tremendous amount from this guy.
And so I'm,
I'm walking back into the tent.
He's in front of the tent.
And I said,
good evening,
gunny.
And I walked by and he didn't say anything and he grabs like the back of my
skivvies shirt and pulls me back towards him.
And he hugged me and he said,
I love you Schick.
And I was like,
I don't know dude.
My hands,
like,
I'm like,
what do I do?
Do I say it back?
Is this a trap?
What do I do this?
And I was like,
screw it man.
I mean,
I've been dirty before.
We'll love you to guns.
And I'll never forget,
he just looked at me right in my face and just said,
you're going to be alright.
Surrender that.
So then I was like,
okay,
something's not right at this point.
I'm 100% convinced something's not right.
I didn't know what it was,
but I knew it wasn't right.
So I broke my cardinal rule and went to the phone to call my family.
And the last person I called was my dad.
And you know,
you have the two,
three second delay.
And I knew it was about 10 30 at night in Shreveport,
Louisiana.
And,
and I knew he was home alone because my step mom and my little brother were at
the Rancho San Antonio and he answers the phone and I said,
hey pop.
And he knows me because I'm the only kid that calls him pop first words out of
his mouth or why am I talking to you?
It's almost like he knew that I knew something wasn't right
and I said,
I just wanted to tell you how much I love you and what you being my father means
to me as your son
because at this point in our life and our journey is father and son was.
That's pretty much where it ended.
He was my dad.
I was a song that was it because my older brother,
he was born in God just touched his forehead and said athlete.
And my dad was a baseball player,
my brother's baseball player.
I always hated it.
I was like,
that is a slow sport known to mankind.
It's like watching paint dry and,
and so I,
I always growing up,
felt like I was always chasing my brother.
I was chasing this,
this unbelievable athlete that I was never going to be better than when it came
to Athleticism,
no matter what sport.
But I was chasing that and then I was like,
okay,
well I'm going to go play baseball.
The try and appease my dad to show him like,
Hey,
I can do this too.
Like I can do it,
and I sucked.
I was never,
I was never very good at it.
You know,
football and knowing now baseball's an art almost.
It's a calculated art.
Whereas with football,
if you can run into another human with a 100% focus and 100% we'll have
breathing.
That man's will by making your body collide with his as hard as you can.
You can play football
to a certain extent,
right?
You can play football.
Why did,
I loved it because for me it was an outlet of the aggression that I had as a kid
growing up in the,
the,
the antithesis of the cookie cutter childhood.
And so at this point that I'm leaving,
you know,
I'm at my father and I was,
we weren't where I felt like we should be as father and son,
you know,
it was just,
and this is a conversation that I've had with my dad since obviously,
and so he,
when he,
when I told them like,
I just want you to know it's important that you know how much I love
and respect you and how much I owe you for being there.
When you were dealt a shitty hand and you had us kids on your own
and you leaned in,
you leaned in and your bolt up and I owe you till I die,
I'll owe you and I needed you to know that.
And so he said,
how long has this passion?
I said,
nine days.
And you know,
he knew not to ask,
where are you going?
What are you doing?
Because the people that listen to your every phone call with your call would be
over.
And he said,
I bet I want to hear from you at nine days.
He said,
I better hear from you in nine days.
I said,
you will pop,
I'll love you man.
And he just said,
I love you too,
and ended with,
you'd better be okay.
And I hung up and it was one of those moments where I was like,
as a,
at the time,
I'm
2121 years old and I realize
I have,
I have no control over anything.
Nothing.
I feel like I think I can,
like I think I have control and in protecting my team and making sure my team's
okay,
I have no control over anything.
It was one of those human moments where I realized
I'm just as vulnerable as everyone else.
There's nothing special about me.
I can be the biggest,
strongest,
toughest.
It doesn't matter.
That does not matter.
Because when it's your time,
it's your time.
That's,
it doesn't matter what you know,
doesn't matter how well trained you are.
If God pulls your card,
you're done.
So it was a very,
very sobering in,
in humbling moment for me.
And we left out the next morning to go to Alice or go to do lab.
We get out to do love.
And you know we started
patrolling the perimeter and for reactions called Gore's me in the react team
which means nine Marines would go to wherever the reactors and but I always had
that have you feeling in my gut that
it didn't affect my job didn't affect our day to day operations and what we were
doing but I knew
it was something was coming and then one night we had a,
we had two guys come in the main gate and they were in like a white opal
pulled in the main gate and pretty much just laid down on both sides of the car,
obviously not normal behavior.
Well these guys were high profile targets that once we find out who they are and
radio battalion,
they were like,
Hey,
don't let them out of your site.
And so we ended up having,
and for the react team we had two,
two Dorsaut top humvees.
That's what we had to operate in.
And the guy,
we had one guy in the back of one vehicle,
another guy in the back of the second vehicle and they both had MTM argue boxes
duct taped on their head because we were out of hoods and so improvise,
adapt and overcome.
And um,
you know,
had them Hawk just had had them,
they weren't going anywhere.
Well,
so the Iraqi national guard also got to be on the same net frequencies,
US radio frequency.
So they're hearing all the transmissions.
Next thing you know,
they show up and there's a lot of them and they pull in and circle us.
Obviously show of force and say,
you know these guys,
same thing you went through about the IED maker,
the bomb maker.
And he's,
you know,
these guys,
they're no threat.
These guys are good.
You need to let them go.
No,
no.
And I remember one of the guys that was like the kernel of that rack,
national guard and he said,
well you need the term interpreters there.
And I remember him saying something along the lines of,
we need to take a direct order from a superior officer.
And we were like,
hey bro,
I don't know if you've been working with the army or whatever.
We don't give a shit who you are because we know that you're probably a bad guy.
So no,
they're not leaving.
And,
um,
that situation got super gnarly super quick.
And I was thinking to myself,
like
I remember telling him,
one of the guys that,
uh,
had a nine to one of the dude's head and I told him if he's so much of sneezes,
pushes brains to the side of his head and I could hear that Beretta nine Mil.
I could hear it rattling.
Cause he was,
it was,
I'm sure it was from pre Vietnam,
isn't marines,
you know,
and I could hear,
but I could hear this slide or rattling against the barrel.
And I was like,
dude,
that dude is shaking heart.
But I knew if that dude so much just sneezed,
I knew it would happen.
And so we were,
by the grace of God,
we had a cause.
We were,
we were part of weapons platoon,
but weapons company,
it just got done doing according to knock or whatever they were doing.
And they're listening to this transmission over the net.
So we're talking about battalion saying like,
hey this is escalating and there's about 65 of them and 10 of us.
So they were heavily outnumbered obviously,
but we need some serious shit is going to go down.
And so weapons company pulls in.
I don't even remember if it's an hour later,
three hours.
It seemed like a fricking Aternity where they pull in and make a circle around
the I and g good times bro.
And of course the weapons company are the ones with,
you know the mark itns 50 cows,
84 we had 84 too.
But I mean they had all the big,
you know,
when they pull in you,
you know like okay,
those guys have big stuff that obviously goes bang a lot.
And so these guys pulled in and it was almost in unison,
the Iraqi National Guard guys dropping their Aka his hands in the air.
No,
me stolen.
he used to and I was like,
Yep,
those are homeys,
you know,
like,
so let's,
and so those guys,
they take them and take them back to Alice sod,
you know,
and then they,
they popcorn fart,
disappear.
There's gone.
I mean,
I'm sure some super secret squirrel agency came in and got him or whatever.
Well,
we finally go to bed down and um,
I go up to the command post and doc was up at the command post was his turn to
sit in the vehicle that powers the command post and it was his turn to count the
flares,
Long Euphrates.
And when was it shot?
What color was it?
And then we turn it into Intel and then they try and crack a code decipher code.
And so we saw it to dock and tell him,
I'm like,
you know,
like,
hey man,
this was not,
he's like,
I know I was listening to it on that.
That was crazy.
And so I,
I can barely keep my eyes open at this point.
Drillings worn off and you know,
series of high,
high series,
a low lows,
no gray area.
That's what being a grunt is and being a warfighter is.
And so I told Doc,
I got a bit down smoked and a good bed down.
No worries,
man.
And uh,
so I go and take my boots off and I'm,
I'm so tired.
I take my boots off and lay on my cot
and Iraq being Iraq,
especially in Oh for not even 20 minutes later.
I mean my dogs didn't even start to breathe,
react.
And I'm like,
Kate Murphy,
your Dick.
You know,
it was like,
if that's the way Murphy Werx sued,
not a fan,
not a fan of,
of that Murphy.
And so,
you know,
wake up and I'm like,
all right,
gotta wake up team.
So I rub,
rub their backs and whisper sweet nothings in their ear because that's how we do
it.
And we,
these guys,
they're all pissed.
Like,
you know,
this is a bunch of bullshit.
Like,
hey man,
it's cause it's the paycheck.
That's why we do it.
What was the call that came in one day?
What was going down?
It was,
um,
I think it was someone in our,
someone had gotten in the Yale wasn't supposed to be in the Eo and you know,
neutralized type thing and I get up and I'm,
I'm carrying,
I think I slide my boots on him time yet and I walk out of the tent as soon as I
walk out of the 10th.
That feeling I had in my gut went right in my throat,
rolls right into my throat and I knew we were about to get hit.
I knew ensures I was at the sun was going to come up.
I knew we were going to get it.
I didn't know how bad it was gonna be.
I didn't know by what,
I didn't know to the extent,
but I knew it was going to happen.
And so I buy the,
I took measures and did things that otherwise wouldn't have done.
And you mean call it my grandfather talked to me from beyond the grave.
You can call it God and call whatever you want.
And good news is that I can have my beliefs and you can have yours and odds are
not going to get our heads cut off because we live in a free society.
And so I,
my commanding officer was out there
to do a report on what had went down the night before he's sleeping.
And,
but I knew he had a bomb blanket.
And so I took the bumbling get out of the passenger seat of the,
one of the only up armored Humvees you had at the time.
And I went to the lead vehicle and I told the driver,
scoot over to the lead vehicles to this day,
have great friend of mine put the bomb blanket down and I told the guys button
up if they gave it to us for protection,
but put it on now,
which I usually wasn't real hardcore about just because when it's 120 something
degrees and you,
you have all that gear on,
more gear is not optimal to the whole being comfortable thing.
And um,
I mean,
I'm sure the guys knew something was up.
And then I take the radio from the Aro and uh,
everything's buttoned up.
Flak jacket,
Kevlar,
Wiley acts is shatter shatterproof that they should have said kind of shatter
proof.
And then,
um,
it's,
you know,
the groin protector,
if they gave it,
we had it on.
And so I,
I get on the horn with my right arm.
I'm driving with my left,
I gassed it and I'm,
so you're driving,
I'm driving,
I'm driving.
And uh,
just because I,
you would put the bomb blanket under the,
under the driver's seat.
And so I don't know,
it was just reaction.
I mean,
it was something was guiding me to do all these things.
You know,
I'm not,
I can't tell you what the Lotto numbers are.
Like,
I can't tell.
I'm not,
I don't have VSP it Usb,
I'm not a fortune teller.
Like something was guiding me to do these things and you just put that bomb
Lincoln under there just cause you just told me,
put it in the driver's seat and get in the driver's seat.
Take the radio.
I did all these things,
I punch it three minutes later,
had a triple stack pressure plate ignited.
So three,
three,
one five,
five Mike,
Mike's and layman's terms.
What that means is the big ass bomb.
Yeah.
That's about what,
75 pounds of explosives.
It's a lot.
It's a freaking big blowup directly beneath me.
Blew me about 30 feet to the top of the Humvee.
Stuck to any with my head.
Cause again,
marines believe in good form.
And um,
I like to say because God's a comedian.
I never lost conscious on everyone into shock.
I remember the whole thing.
Took the Black Hawk 42 minutes,
come get me.
So I love to look at people when they're like,
it's such a long day at work today.
Like,
really,
hold on,
let me throw some perspective your way.
But that's,
I'm only when I'm in a bad mood.
But it was a,
I knew midair.
It was bad.
I knew it was bad.
I knew this was not good at all.
And when I hit the deck,
I couldn't breathe because the,
um,
as you know,
this,
this series of events and an explosion,
a million things happen in a nanosecond,
especially when it's that big of an explosion.
And so it was when the dashboard disengaged and steer will hook me and my chest
explode.
It all my mags hit me in my chest and temporary collapse,
both my lungs before I was blown out.
A whole series of things happened before,
during this process causing injuries.
And,
and um,
I hit the deck and I knew I'm hurt bad.
I can't breathe,
can't hear anything.
It was just ringing.
And first thing I do is talk to God.
First thing I did before I even did self assessment is it talk to guys I can't
see out of my right eye.
Thanks.
This shatterproof while he likes this,
but w because they shattered both of them by the way.
Yeah.
There's,
there's something called the triple stacked id.
I don't know what glasses are going to hang with that one saying,
hey,
listen man,
false advertisement.
Right.
But we,
um,
I'm,
they're,
they're a great company.
I'm just,
you know,
Kinda find light in every situation.
But we,
but I talk to God right away.
And this is exactly what I said.
Hey big man,
I know this is bad.
All I'm asking is that you don't take me in front of my family.
It's all I'm asking.
Don't let my brother's watching me die.
As soon as kids leave the deck,
I'm all yours.
Just please don't let my brother's watching me die.
That's all I cared about.
And then I started the self assessment,
which starts with checking your junk is the only thing that worked was my right
arm.
Everything else was shattered or broken.
Go and find out all my ribs are broken.
So that didn't help anything.
And um,
so I go,
I move my drawing flap and check my junk.
And I was like,
okay,
that's there.
Everything else has been datable like we're,
we'll work through,
we will survive.
And um,
but then I looked at my,
uh,
my right leg look normal,
but my right,
but my right foot and ankle hurt really bad.
So it's like,
okay,
it's probably broken.
Well,
I didn't know it was crushed.
Was the firewall in the Humvee folded up?
Trust my right foot before I was blown out.
My left,
I looked at my left arm and I remember seeing like daylight through my left arm.
Part of my left hand was hanging down by my elbow.
So I was like,
okay,
that's might not,
might not keep the left arm.
And I looked down at my left leg,
which was turned outward.
Like if you're sitting down with both legs,
like you're going to touch her toes.
My left leg was turned outward to the left and my foot was inverted,
like with my toes pointing at me and my boot was blown off.
But my,
but everything was there.
It was all over the place.
But it was there.
So saw my fibia and my Tibia saw all the damage that was done to my left leg and
cause my McKameys were shredded.
And I thought two things when I saw that first thing I thought was,
that's not supposed to be like that.
Second thing I thought was
that that was confirmation that that was a very big explosion.
To be able to blow a laced up combat boot off your leg and not take your leg
with it is a massive explosion,
was crazy.
And so at this point I'm thinking how was the yeah,
blown eardrums was the other worst injury man.
So literally blew up straight up directly beneath Mia Straight and straight up.
They must have had it buried a little bit enough that it projected right up into
you.
And it was so that standoff we had the night before,
it's when they buried it.
So all that was was a diversion because everyone was glued to the radios,
you know,
so it was,
and it was in a perfect spot.
It was the one spot around that entire area of operation that you couldn't have
ice directly on the one spot.
Yeah.
And so at this point,
the guys finally make it up to me and they're
really there a lot of freaking out.
Cause I mean I did the Humvee move.
Oh yeah.
It was blossoms.
Who did get blown up.
Yeah.
But it was,
I'll tell you this,
if we were in a up armored Humvee,
everyone was,
would be dead from overpressure.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There've been nowhere for it to go.
Everyone would have died.
It would have been,
but it was blown up and over
to the right and um,
second vehicle one affected.
Um,
but the guys aren't up to me
at this point.
I'm back to telling God like,
hey man,
just remember our deal.
Remember our deal and um,
guys,
okay,
shake.
We got you bro.
We got,
you know,
we got you hang tough and how to know where I was able to take a breath and the
first thing I said was developed through safety and they were like,
oh shit.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
no shit.
What's coming next?
Yeah.
I,
how do we know we're not about to start taking fire,
which probably was,
was unlikely cause there was no cover in that.
I mean there would have been nowhere for him to hide it and it would have been a
suicide mission on their part.
Um,
because we had one still very functional to 40,
and we knew how to employ that weapon,
but they get me back on the second vehicle,
which was like I said,
it's the operational and get me back up to the command post and
man it,
and little did I know that that's that at that moment,
that's when my battle,
my personal war started right then that day.
And I get up there and,
um,
doc,
same doc that I was talking to those in the Humvee,
counting the flares,
it was working on me.
And uh,
I was,
I was young,
I was pissed,
I was not happy and I was yelling at dock and it was like,
doc,
you got to hit me.
He got to hit me.
And he's like,
I already did.
And so I'm like,
you're,
I was like,
you're stingy bastard because you don't even hit me with two sticks of morphine.
And I knew he had more.
And all I knew is I was in a lot of pain.
He had the remedy and he wasn't giving it to me.
And I was like,
that's,
that's kind of bullshit.
You know,
I didn't understand that the muscles around my lungs can relax so much myself.
Gate,
I didn't know they didn't care.
I just knew I was in a lot of pain.
He had drugs and he was not giving him to me a little bit.
I know the guy was,
you know,
the,
the tip of the spirits saving my life.
And um,
while this whole situation was really gnarly and very painful and very,
very humbling,
I wouldn't trade it at all because I got to tell every one of those guys,
every single one of them
is just like talking to my dad.
But I was talking to my brothers,
just got to tell every one of them how much I loved them,
how much they meant to me,
how much I respected them,
and that this is real.
What we're doing is real.
Look at me,
look at me and remember this,
and go fight your balls off because this is what they want to do to every one of
us.
Okay?
Don't let it happen again.
Just,
just learn from this.
You have to fight for me now.
And that was,
you know,
it was a situation where,
and they kept telling men and they kept telling me,
uh,
you know,
he Schick is your bird home.
It's your bird home.
And it would piss me off every time they said it.
And it was like,
I don't want to go home,
shut up.
I don't want to go home.
She could get to go see your family.
You are my family.
I'll see them when it's time to see them,
you know,
it was that.
So there's this whole series of thoughts and emotions and uh,
you know what I mean?
It was everything from laughing and crying and everything in between.
The laughing again and they were scrambling to get the Med evac there.
And the problem was that we didn't have any fighter escorts and that's took
forever because they were all dispatched,
so forth.
I mean,
there they were all scrambled.
And so it was finally,
it was a Texas Army Nash Air National Guard pilot that heard the transmission
that,
you know,
this marine out of Texas category for rapidly approaching category five to
category four is urgent surgery.
Kind of got to go with five being expected.
And um,
he finally got his crew and said,
screw the rules,
we're going to get this summary and eat loaded.
Came and got me.
And um,
I remember when the guys were loaded me on the Black Hawk and my platoon
sergeant was the last one on.
And um,
and that was,
that was uh,
that was an emotional experience dude because it was
anyway w two sergeants on and he kisses me on my forehead and he says,
we'll see you soon.
Jack London,
cause he always called me Jack London because my first generation marines,
Jak one and Schick,
second generations Jack and chick junior.
And so he always called me Jack London cause I guess Jake wasn't good enough.
But when he said it,
he was trying not to cry and I could tell in his eyes he was lying,
which kind of motivated me.
And I was like,
well,
I'll show you.
I'm going to prove you wrong and you are going to see me again
even though it wasn't my choice.
Right.
And so the,
the bird takes off man.
And I'm out of everything I've been through from
day one to now.
That was the hardest moment.
Hands Down,
no questions asked was leaving those guys hands down.
That was the hardest moment because that's when
I was taught just how human I am and just how irrelevant I,
and it was,
um,
a very,
very hard experience to leave my family in harm's way and there wasn't a damn
thing I could do about it.
You talk about being humbled that will humble you
and we get up in the,
in the air and I'm able,
I'm able to get the attention and one of the litter crews,
a young dude,
I mean again,
I'm 21 and he was probably 18,
19,
but military years.
That's eons.
And he comes up and he gets right.
He puts his left your right in front of my face and I yelled as loud as I could
exist.
You know in the back one was birds.
You don't have a headset on,
you can't hear shit.
And I yelled as hard as I could,
how long?
And I remember when I did that I felt like leave my body.
I knew I was dying.
Did they tourniquet you already the doctor over and over.
I mean I was bleeding everywhere.
And so did you have,
did you have shell shrapnel wounds?
Yeah.
So it was not just your leg and
add a trauma and my,
my Chin side of my face,
my,
my neck.
Um,
when your right arm,
left arm,
left leg,
it was,
it was bad.
And um,
had I not had that Sapi plate in my flat,
I'd have been dead.
There was a big,
a piece of,
there was a piece sticking out.
It was bigger than this cable sticking out right out of the center and my gun,
he took pictures of my gear damn showing guys like,
Hey,
no matter how uncomfortable you are there,
this is why you don't cut corners.
And um,
but this dude on the litter crew radios up front to the captain and comes back
and he yells in my right ear,
12 Mike's as loud as he can or 12 minutes.
And so I was,
I immediately talked to God again right away,
like a big man.
I'm going to have to renege on that original verbal agreement was,
I'm pretty sure I can do 12 more minutes.
And um,
obviously,
you know,
he gave me that because I'm talking to,
but um,
we go and we landed it and blood,
which is just a makeshift filled hospital at the time.
I'm sure you remember from seeing the no four but it was,
and they pulled me off the bird and I'm immediately,
immediately started working on me.
I mean it was,
I was not happy about the situation because they kept saying name,
rank,
social name,
social.
Cause they wanted me alert and there were,
you know,
and I knew what they were doing and I was like,
but it's like if you slam your finger in the door,
right?
And your buddies right there and he's like,
Hey,
are you okay?
Are you okay?
And every time they say it,
the pain goes up.
Like I would be golden if you would just shut your gaffer,
you know.
And so I just yelled,
finally in pointed with my right arm was only at work it that,
hey,
it's tattooed right through my ribs.
I'm done talking
like I'm going to show them.
Right.
And I didn't insight into organs and they get me in the tent.
And um,
they,
they loaded me up with some,
with some of the good shit cause I felt it definitely helped the pain,
but I'll still a massive amounts of pain and I'll never forget,
one of the surgeons was sewing up my face and he said,
oops.
And I looked at,
I was like,
well what do you mean use doc?
And he's like,
Hey,
sorry,
marina dicked up on your stitches are going to have start again.
And I said,
Hey doc,
at this point I have the sheet up to my neck.
And I was,
as I said,
hey doc,
I don't know if you've seen seen my body from the neck down,
but I'm fairly certain the scratches on my face or the least of our worries.
And I think he had the,
uh,
the analysis is not mad at that moment because I don't,
that's the last thing I remember until I was woken up by nurse Jax who,
uh,
she had told me,
she woke me up and you know,
I'm coming out of the or and um,
and that's still on ballade.
Yeah.
And she says,
I'm a marine.
I'm sorry to tell you this,
we had to take your right foot.
It was dead when you got here.
There's no blood flow.
And it was crushed.
And I remember thinking to myself like,
Shit,
they took the wrong foot because it was my left one.
That was really cool stuff.
And so then I think like,
you know,
it's good enough for government work,
right,
whatever.
And I'm just,
it's bloods.
I'm just like,
you know,
in a long day just got long.
So you're completely contorted and twisted and backwards and left foot.
It was,
was the one that made it well and that looked pretty normal.
Do you look completely normal?
With my boot on looked everything was normal,
but then she described it to me.
She,
she said when we,
when you got here,
imagine like a surgical glove but in the shape of a foot as opposed to a hand
being filled with sand,
that was your right foot.
She said everything.
It was everything and it was completely crushed.
It was to the point to where there was it cut off the blood supply.
And so somehow none of my major arteries and my left arm or left leg got hit.
And so there was still hope for my left leg and my left arm.
But,
um,
she ended up,
we ended up blowing up,
um,
on the bird to go to Germany and she flew with me to Germany because I was,
I was not out of the woods by any stretch.
It was going to be a,
this was going to be a long and arduous recovery process.
And I remember getting to Germany
or no,
I'm sorry,
before we left,
this was four days after I talked to my,
my dad.
So I called my dad from the sat phone and they'd given me and my dad answered
the phone and
said,
hey pop.
And he said,
why am I talking to you?
I said,
they got me.
He said,
what do you mean they got me?
So they got me dead and I'm hurt.
He said,
how bad are you hurt?
So they'd take my right foot.
And there was a pause.
And then he said,
are you gonna make it?
And I said,
I don't know.
He said,
we're waiting first verdant green and you know,
we'll meet you in Germany.
And at this point,
man,
I'm
on that four year old kid again.
It just needs his dad.
And I are,
the last thing I told him was,
um,
was I love them,
but right then I said,
please hurry.
And he said,
we're going to be all right.
I love you and love you too.
That was the hardest phone call I've ever made in my life
because I just see him,
it might as well graduation saying,
why would you do that?
And I'm like,
dammit,
dammit.
He may have had something there like,
and I'm still thinking like a young,
immature kid.
But I knew one thing I wanted my dad.
And so I get to Germany and um,
one of my best friends from high school was a little brother who was like,
my little brother growing up was in the army and um,
he was a scout and he was there in Germany and was able to get word that I was
on my way and he was right there and the ambulance doors open
and he put his head on my chest and he lost.
It started bawling.
And I just remember Thomas,
Hi Josh.
It's all right man.
And um,
you know,
he just kept saying,
not you,
not you.
Not you and he wouldn't leave my side,
you know,
but he had a cell phone and I got to call other people and even when they're
trying to take me to the or to wash me out and reset my left leg and left arm
and Redo the
external fixators use,
like he's walking right next to the bed,
like he's going into the or with me.
And I remember them saying like,
so you can't cut.
And he was like,
the Hell I can't,
what do you,
and I was like,
John,
you can't do like just come on man.
They don't have no drugs for both of us.
But he was,
it was just the girls to show you man.
Like it's,
there were so many experiences throughout this process that just reassured me of
how very real that something bigger than us out there is.
You know,
that they're,
you know,
I was a believer growing up man,
but this was,
there was things that happen that no one could explain that had to be from a
higher power.
And that was just one of them.
One of those moments where I was,
that was a part of me living was Josh being there and me not having to be alone
in that situation.
So I ended up leaving Germany
and I was on,
I was only there for me.
I wasn't even there a full day before they send me to Bethesda.
And um,
I,
I laugh because my family was supposed to meet me in Germany,
but the turnaround is so fast.
The,
you know,
the marines were like,
no,
we're just going to send you to Bethesda.
And I got to Bethesda and um,
man,
those flights,
both flights from Iraqi,
Jeremy,
Jeremy to Bethesda,
every little like bit of turbulence,
every little bump,
every little movement,
it was like being blown up all over again.
It was gnarly.
It cause your,
your body was under,
it was in so much pain.
It was just,
I'd never puked so much because of pain in my life.
And it was one of those things where I was,
again,
every little jar,
every movement was just like yours,
human as they come.
Like there's nothing special about you.
This is not going to get easier.
And I remember the getting there and they're waiting over by the emergency
entrance and
the doors open.
And of course thing of the liaison.
I told my family like,
hey,
Jake's on the runway just touched down and my dad is there and I'm sure I looked
amazing.
My head was the size of a watermelon and I was black and blue and purple and I'm
sure I smelled amazing too.
And my dad put his hand on my chest and he said,
Bubba is that you?
And all I could get out was get your damn hand off my chest because all my ribs
were broken.
And it hurt like hell.
And he looks at my family cause yet that's Jake,
Jake.
And so they load their,
their rolling me on the Gurney and this,
this young sailors pushing me and I remember every little like in the grout that
separates tiles,
like every little bump,
it was like getting blown up again.
And it would just make,
it wouldn't take my pain from six to as much as you could think in the snap of,
I mean,
it was gnarly.
And so I remember he's going to push me on the elevator to take me down to the
ICU.
And you know,
the big gap is separate,
separates the floor and the elevator.
We goes across that and we're in the big elevator where they take the Gurneys,
take the patient's on gurneys.
And so my family's in there with us and he goes across that bump and this dude
is
so young and just,
he was the epitome of a boot.
And so it goes across that gap.
And,
and I,
I knife hand with my right hand and I look up and I say,
if you do that again,
I'm going to take you out.
And my dad last and it looks as a family,
like he's going to be okay.
You know,
and um,
like the dude's meaning to hit gaps,
right.
It's just,
you know,
the,
the problem was,
is I was never trained to be a severely wounded marine.
It wasn't in the handbook.
And so I didn't know what the hell to do and um,
let's just get this
out of the way.
I was never a good patient,
ever.
Not one time.
It was something that I just didn't have in me.
All I knew to do was to be a dick and fight like hell.
And when I fight like hell,
it's,
I'm usually a dick.
That was my survival magazine.
Were you just like angry?
Were you angry or you were hurt and pissed off that you were,
your leg was gone and you're like just pissed.
And so every nurses you're pissed at.
I'm not mad.
Listen,
I'm not angry that my legs gone.
I'm not angry.
I'm angry.
I'm up at that time.
At that time,
I'm not angry that my legs,
I'm not angry.
I never did the why me.
I never not want to this day,
not,
don't have,
I don't believe in that.
I'm angry because my family is back in a god forsaken,
Lynn fighting and there and here I am sucking up oxygen in,
in a hospital bed.
That's why I'm angry.
I'm pissed off at God because it's like,
hey,
you had a perfectly good chance.
Perfectly good chance.
What the hell?
You know,
what the hell that's,
I mean,
what am I supposed to do right from here?
Right now?
What am I doing?
I'm doing no good.
None.
That's why I was angry.
I was angry because I could not contribute to what I was trained to contribute
to with,
with my brother's.
Like that's,
they were there and I was back home in an air conditioned room with a bunch of
people waiting on me.
Hand and foot,
pun totally intended like that,
you know?
That's why I was pissed.
No,
they couldn't understand that.
And I,
and I don't blame them for that to this day.
I don't blame them for that,
but it was,
um,
I don't know for,
we had a lot of guys getting hurt,
a lot of guys getting wounded and I mean,
the hospital was full of guys.
I wasn't the different,
I wasn't special.
I wasn't any better or worse,
or I was just a guy who had a bed.
They work.
So what are they doing?
What are you going through at this point?
You know,
obviously you're going through surgery,
surgery.
It was gnarly.
Yeah.
I mean it was every,
for the first
two and a half,
I guess months I was home.
I was in the,
or every 48 72 hours.
And some of those operations
were like 18,
1920 our operations and their piece and you back together.
And the man robbing from Peter to give to Paul to try and save my left leg and
my left arm and stuff.
It was crazy.
Crazy,
crazy.
How many surgeries do you have stateside?
At 46.
And I had 23 blood transfusions.
I've had a couple surgeries,
had a neck surgery and I had a hernia surgery.
So when you get,
when I got those surgeries right,
like you just feel like
complete crap is there,
you're just going through that every just like almost on a permanent level.
Yeah,
the anesthesia,
the blood loss,
all that stuff.
It's just a,
it's
wake up,
suck,
go to bed,
repeat.
It was nothing.
There was nothing fun about any of it.
And,
um,
I mean it was so bad that
it was like the nurses at the nurses station,
the night nurses,
I'll never forget,
and it happened every night.
They,
they would do paper,
rock,
scissors to see you had to take my chart.
It was that bad in a,
God forbid a psychologist walk or
God forbid it was,
cause I was,
I had nothing to say
so I'm,
I'm kind of,
I just realized I laughed at this.
Right.
And we're at,
you're telling it in a funny way because you're like,
hey,
I was a bad patient,
but the point I was getting at before,
like why you were angry,
but like we're,
we're laughing about it right now,
but you're not kidding like this.
Like you were fucking pissed,
right?
Yeah.
And when someone would come in you'd be like,
you don't get that off me.
I don't want,
if you don't,
what you that like just agro with Pete.
So I,
I had,
this is the rule that I had as a patient,
you're not allowed in my room unless we share DNA or your United States marine.
And that goes for the president on down.
I don't give a shit what your title is or who you are.
Those are the rules.
If you don't have the same DNA as me and you're not United States marine,
don't come in my room because I'm going to let you know you're not allowed.
And that was because I'm in survival mode and survival mode and I didn't know
what that looked like.
I was making it up as I go,
as I went.
You know what I mean?
It was,
it didn't matter what surgeon was talking to me,
what professional with a bunch of letters after his or her name.
I didn't care.
I did not care because my mindset was like,
I'm trying to figure out how to get to the next breath.
Okay.
In the least painful way as possible.
And it was something that it was,
um,
like I said,
I went from being one of the most,
the part of one of the most elite fighting forces known to mankind,
to not being able to use the bathroom on my own.
Now I was in a hospital bed for months over night.
I mean it it the drop of a hat that's not humble pie that's in hell on the
factory.
Knowing that my guys,
I knew Fallujah,
we were already drawn the war path or plan for Fallujah.
And so it's like here I am
and
not broken.
I hate that terminology.
But here I am completely fractured
and,
and
these guys are hooking and jabbing and they're asking me what kind of,
what color Jello I want.
And it's like
I don't need,
I don't need to eat.
I need to get through the next minute.
And then the minute after that I get and nothing else matters.
Nothing.
I just need to survive second by second,
minute by minute and breath by breath
and continue to believe I'm worth this thing called life.
I need to keep fighting.
And a byproduct of that is it.
I was a giant Dick,
but I kept fighting.
It wasn't pretty,
And how long were you in Bethesda for?
Some only been says a few months and then the move me,
matter of fact,
my,
my dad goes to a Walter Reed and then he comes back and he says,
Yo Jake,
this is your deal and let me back up a bit.
My Dad,
my brother are both pretty squeamish when it comes to blog and stuff like that,
like it was just don't do well with it.
My Dad was an executive,
may just retired last year and executive Baker started as a window,
a teller at a bank.
He worked his way up,
did not leave my bedside for 62 days.
Okay.
Didn't leave my side no matter how hard I was on him or they did not leave my
side.
And I like to say that if had it not been for this explosion,
I would not be nearly as close to mine.
You can't,
I don't think I could possibly be closer to my dad as I am now or my brother.
Same thing,
same relationship that before just didn't,
we just didn't have it.
And I think it was because there was always that Alpha struggle whereas it had
to take one of the office having a thumb war with the grim reaper for everyone
to say,
what the hell are we doing
and why are we doing it?
Yeah.
That's why I was just one of the reasons I wouldn't trade it cause that that's
beautiful man.
And I got to experience something that a lot of people don't get to experience
that they die wondering,
did I send everything I needed to say?
Did I love as hard as I needed to love.
I don't have to wonder about that now and neither did the love and be loved.
Everything else is filler.
Yeah.
So that's why I would not trade it.
But I remember my dad told me with my left arm one night they,
they were telling me,
okay Jay,
can we have this?
We have to reconstruct your left arm.
And the bottom graph took the first time,
but the top graph take
and the second time they tried doing it,
I remember that I woke up all,
they were cutting the graft off.
And um,
that was an early experience when I was a week for like literally 0.5 seconds
before they knocked me back out.
And uh,
did you hit anybody in that point?
Five seconds.
I tried to hit people all the time.
I think it was stupid.
I mean,
I messed up stitches and staples and stuff all the time and I took them,
I took my own out all the time.
I got in trouble drugged up or you during this time,
dude,
I was on enough drugs to like kill a herd of elephants because everybody's body
reacts differently to drugs,
right?
Either you're except him and you'd doesn't take a lot with mind fights,
everything.
You know what I mean?
Which is not surprising,
but my,
it takes,
if it takes you,
are you one pill,
it's going to take me five.
And so every operation I had,
because these were major movies,
were intrusive operations.
These weren't like,
hey,
we're going to go and take the staples out of the,
no,
these were were going in and cutting you back open and we're going to power wash
this part of your body out.
And I mean they were intrusive operations or we're going to go and take skin
from this part of your body and put it on this other part of your body.
And so,
or we're going to take this bone out here and we're going to try and craft it
over there.
And so it was one of those things where I knew like,
okay,
these are some serious things were for six months to a year.
Like I didn't know if I was going to keep my left leg and my left arm because
they were,
I was going through all these operations to save these two appendages that we're
in.
For all intents and purposes,
I was a Guinea pig for a lot of stuff,
which I'm okay with.
It was a better me than my brothers.
I'm all right with that small price to pay.
It'd be one of the world's finest.
Right.
And so they,
I remember the night before,
um,
I had this major operation on my left arm and this was when the graph didn't
take the second one and they were doing a bone graft and,
uh,
they amputated my right,
like again,
to take some of the Tibia from my right leg to try and grafted in my left arm
because five inches of my own on my left arm was blown out.
And,
um,
my dad asked the doc,
I'll never forget it.
He said,
hey doc,
how'd you sleep the next morning?
And he said,
I didn't.
My Dad said,
well,
why didn't you sleep?
Cause I did Jake's operation about a thousand times in my head.
And my dad was like,
okay,
I think I'm okay with that.
And then,
um,
he,
I remember him asking me,
Hey Schick,
do you,
do you mind if we amputate your fourth digit on your left hand because I don't
think it's going to be of any use to you.
And it gives,
my metacarpal was blown out from my ring finger.
I said,
if I wake up and there's anything else,
cut off my body,
don't be on the right side of my bed because I will choke you out in front of
God and everybody.
And he been knowing me all two worlds at the time.
Said,
all right,
I'm going to take that as a no and a everybody got a good laugh and then they
knocked me out again.
But um,
so that graft didn't take and they're not in the back out then they call in a
specialist.
And so what they had to do was
put me in an induced coma and cut my abdomen open and then put my left arm in my
abdomen and then sold my happen and shot to grow skin over my left arm.
So much interestingly,
same,
uh,
Lou Lou polar junior had the same cause he had severely,
got his hands jacked up and they did the same thing multiple times to him.
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
who would have thought that's a thing,
and then they,
so my dad and I had this thing where I would wake up every morning cause he was
always there during the day.
Then someone else come at night.
And so I would say,
you know,
hey dad,
it's
Monday,
April 16th,
whatever.
And just to make sure I still had somewhat reliable cognitive function functions
going on.
You know,
and I'm trying to exercise as my frontal lobes as much as I can and making sure
these executive functions are still working the way they are because I was
already told you've got post traumatic stress track ran injury,
which I was like,
whatever,
no that's made up stuff by people in white coats with too much time on their
hands.
That do will not affect me.
I'm a marine.
No.
And um,
so I'm coming out of this,
uh,
this coma,
that was the first time that I,
my brother came in for the first time and I remember he,
he came in and uh,
I could see,
cause what sucked was as early on in the induced coma.
Like,
I could be alert,
but I couldn't obviously couldn't say anything cause I was intubated.
So I did machine breathing for me.
I was completely paralyzed from the neck down,
couldn't move anything.
And it only lasted at first.
They only did it for a day or so because it was so gnarly that my,
my BP and everything would freak out.
My blood pressure go up when I would see someone in my family because I felt
like I was trapped in my own.
I'm a prisoner in my own body.
Somebody get me the hell out of this coma.
You can't move and can't talk.
Nothing.
And yet your conscious,
yeah.
Isn't the purpose of being an induced coma.
So in concert,
right,
so they,
they,
this is just prior to them and deucing the coma.
Oh,
okay.
And so it was just before it,
but then my brother came in and it was the first time that my brother had been
able to see me.
He was in college at the time and playing ball and brother came in and sat down
in the chair.
So we'll first,
when he goes to walk in and I see him come in the door in the ICU and he leaves,
he,
he like took a half step in.
He turned around,
he bolted.
And this is the queasiness factor?
No,
I think this is,
no,
I think it,
for him it was an emotion.
He didn't want to be emotional and me,
no,
he was emotional,
which I knew exactly why I had to leave the room.
So it's like,
it's obsolete.
It might as well just come all the way in.
I know what you're doing.
And so,
but then he comes back in and he sits down in the chair on the right side of my
bed and grabs my right hand and he puts his,
his forehead on my hand and he just starts crying and he just starts repeating
over and over again.
Thank you for not died.
Thank you for not dying.
And I was like,
dude,
anytime you want to shut up about that,
like it would be awesome.
Because it was getting,
I mean it was getting too,
right.
So my BP started going up and they're like,
hey,
you gotta leave.
Like you can't stay in here.
So then they realize like,
okay,
we gotta,
we gotta knock them out.
And I mean,
cause they tried taping the windows so I couldn't see it,
but then it just was too much.
And so they,
that's when they completely put me in the coma.
And that was for,
it was like 30 days or something.
And I remember coming out of it and telling my dad,
like,
we didn't do scores for 30 days to grow that around my arm.
And so they cut it out and then it took,
thankfully it did.
That was the last resort for my left arm.
It was,
if that didn't take,
they're going to have to amputate below my elbow,
within my dad weeks or a week of I'm coming out and I looked at my dad and my
dad,
it's Monday,
April 16.
And he was like,
well no,
it's,
uh,
what,
what happened was,
and then I'm like,
it did no one want to run this by me.
He was like,
no,
they figured you'd be against it.
So it's like whatever shit,
just,
uh,
put it on my tab.
It's like,
but I remember my dad going over to Walter,
he,
it was time my dad told them like,
hey,
listen,
I can afford to fly up here and see my son every week,
most of his family,
because I'm still not out of the woods.
Most of his family can't afford to come to Maryland from Louisiana or Texas to
come,
you know,
see them often.
And so he goes to Walter Reed and came back and he told me,
he said,
Bob,
this is your deal.
This is,
but no son of mine is going to go to that hospital.
That's what I mean.
Obviously I'm going to take your word for it.
It's not like I can skip over there and go check it out.
And they said,
okay.
Well,
we had a friend that worked at the Pentagon who was a one star and my dad and my
step mom contacted him and just said,
hey,
listen,
we got to get Jay closer to home.
And so I actually went to,
they sent me to BMC in San Antonio.
And,
um,
I like to say that's accounts for 50% of my potion.
Nitris cause I was the only marine and army facility and sorry,
I'm not sorry about that,
but it was a great hospital that they did just a good work is Bethesda and um,
you know,
but when they,
when they shipped me,
they moved me way too soon and I just,
my body wasn't ready for it and we had to stop and I believe it's called Scott
Air Force Base in Illinois.
Three flying.
Yeah.
I'm a bird.
And so we stopped and Scott and um,
I guess we didn't know that we were stopping and I had only had enough,
well enough medications in my nerve blockers for set amount of time to get to
San Antonio.
Well that stuff was,
they wanted to do a little layover.
Yeah.
So I'm pissed.
I wake up when we're there and this gun,
he walks up to me and he's like,
hey,
hey corporal.
Sure.
He get a welcome with Scott Air Force base,
um,
gunny schmuck and telly.
And I was like,
where the Hell Scott Air Force Base and who the hell are you?
Um,
because my,
my tax at this point is gone way out the window.
Did Not matter your rank like it did not matter.
And because I'm at the point where I'm like,
what are they going to do?
Shave my head and send me and I rack please,
you'd be doing me a favor.
But so I'm pissed.
And I called my dad and I'm like,
I don't know who fucked this up but I need you to unfuck it right now.
And he got pissed.
I was pissed at him.
Something was out of his control,
you know,
and he was like,
Jake,
oh,
you'll fine.
Go back to go back to Bethesda.
I don't care what you know.
And it was,
you know,
I,
I was owed that in a lot more.
And so they get me in the hospital and my,
and my buddy just starts to shut down.
And so the next thing is in the hospital and Scott Scott,
and this is not like a major,
like a legit,
like they stopped,
stopped like,
so then it's a delay for me to even go to San Antonio because bigger to get you
to recover kind of.
Yeah.
And so that series of events happens there,
which was crazy.
So I go into this shock effect where,
you know,
I'm,
I'm unconscious and uh,
this is another one of those moments where the higher power thing,
I'm coming out of it.
And,
uh,
my,
my left head,
my turns,
my head is turned to my left and the door to my room opens.
I knew whoever was about to walk in the door.
Like I just felt like a spiritual presence.
Like I just felt,
I knew whoever that was was a person of faith,
like personally,
God knew it,
knew it,
no doubt about it,
felt it.
When the door opened,
the dude comes around the corner and introduced himself and it's the base
chaplain.
And I was
like,
okay,
well that's,
that's that.
And uh,
and he said,
hey,
I'm chaplain.
So,
and I said,
I knew,
I knew before you even for,
I saw you as soon as the door opened.
Like I felt,
I felt the presence of a higher being.
Like I felt it,
I knew it and like this really like he,
you could tell he was moved by it.
I wouldn't say it to blow smoke up his ass.
I just knew the dude was a man of God.
And I mean it again,
can't explain it.
It's the whole thing.
The whole word faith comes in,
look it up.
Sometime you got to utilize it.
But the um,
so then he walks in and starts talking to me.
So we have this long conversation of which I can't remember most of the next,
the next day is when I'm leaving and he brings his whole family.
He had like four or five kids and as we brought his wife and the all the nurses
and I mean the airmen and the reserve marines and army guys like made this line
on either side of the back doors of the bird.
And it was like,
like I don't rate what you guys are doing but appreciate it.
Like I can dig it right.
But I didn't,
I was just thinking like,
it's a little much,
but thank you.
You know?
And it was,
but it was like,
you know,
who the hell am I to take away from their right to honor their brother and like,
who am I to do that?
They're just showing love all the way,
not halfway.
And I,
and so of course me being me at the time,
I didn't look at it that way.
I was just like,
I'm naked in front of everyone type feeling.
I'm just uncomfortable right now.
And so they,
they load me up and we fly from um,
Scott to we're going to Bam cu and we stop over.
And,
uh,
I was,
it was all Pasa and on the way I can see the,
the load master mouth to one of the other,
one of the crewman,
we're about to fly around a tornado.
I read his lips and I'm like,
Hey God,
like,
come on man,
throw due to bone like robot.
I'm going to survive all the stuff I've survived.
And if you let me get taken out by a tornado,
like we're,
we're going to be fighting.
This is bullshit.
I'm just thinking like Murphy back off Bro.
Just back off.
But it's just these little moments where you find light in these heavy
situations and I didn't know that we were stopping and I'll pass.
So we stopped and I'll pass on.
I'm pissed.
Why are we stopping and why aren't we in San Antonio?
Well cause we had to drop off someone who's gay and there's return in the body.
And I was like,
okay,
I'm a major dick and I get it.
You know,
it was like,
well shit could you told me that?
And they probably did tell me but I'm on so many drugs I'm going to remember
about 0.2 seconds of an hour conversation I had with you.
So we get to San Antonio again,
my body,
it was bad.
I mean my buddy does the same thing I did at Scott.
And then next thing I know I'm in the ICU again and now the Olr and I ended up
doing
15 months and Banksy and um,
man,
every operation it was just more drugs,
more drugs,
more drugs and a series of events happened to Bamf.
See I'm the only marine there,
which I stayed in.
It was bad because I mean you can only call a marine and soldier so many times
before.
I'm going to let you know that that bothers me.
And if I wanted to be a soldier,
I would have joined the fricking army.
Stop calling me a soldier.
That's just the marine thing.
It's a pride thing.
Absolutely.
A fricking pride thing.
If you don't like it would you,
would you call chesty puller soldier?
Cause if you would,
you're ignorant.
And my thing was is like just utilize some tact
and so they ended up putting the,
the Ega,
the Marine Corps sill on my door and just to let people know a little heads up.
Yeah,
same rules though.
You don't share my DNA and your 99 states marine don't come in my room
still.
So I didn't meet,
I missed,
I missed out on meeting a lot of quote unquote famous people and politicians
that I'm sure there because they care and a bunch of other people and it was
because of that role.
And then the secretary of the army or the surgeon general,
I'm sorry,
surgeons,
German was coming and they were like,
corporal shake,
we really,
you know,
we need you to wake up and shave and you're going to come see the surgeon
general.
And I was like,
okay,
yeah,
I'm going to do that.
Obviously I didn't.
And so I have people coming up to my room and they're like,
corporal shack,
the surgeon general's downstairs,
you were supposed to be in your electrical wheelchair down there meeting them.
And I'm like,
what?
Part of my face says I give a shit that they're here.
I don't even know if it's a man or a woman and I don't care if they want to see
me.
You know where my room is.
Do I go to his or her office and say,
Hey,
I'm going to need you downstairs cause I'm coming.
No,
no I don't.
They're a person just like me,
except they prob something tells you that pain level's probably not where mine
is right now
and no,
I'm not going to shave either.
So you can just just eat a whole bag of dicks cause I don't care.
And so again,
great patient.
Really,
really good patient.
So you're the drugs at this point that they're putting,
you amass all kinds of pain killers and
do you even do,
is there any point where you start realizing like,
oh I'm not going to be okay without these things.
I want them all the time.
Not once.
So at this point,
no.
So you're just thinking that's just the way it is.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hey look,
I'm,
I'm badly wounded.
I need painkillers.
Part of the game.
Yeah.
Right.
Part of the game.
At this point I'm thinking I have,
this is probably the operation like 35 36 and it's so bad that they have me now
I'm having to recover in the ICU after every operation because they're having a
monitor,
my breathing and my heart rate because I'm on so many drugs.
And so at this point they've given me what they feel like,
okay,
we cannot just give them more of any,
we can't give him more dilaudid,
demerol or fentanyl or et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so they give me,
this was the first time that I had experienced after one of these operations,
ketamine and
I was such a,
this is bad because of the guy comes in and start administering the ketamine and
uh,
I'll never forget this.
And he goes,
he starts to administer it through my,
one of my view that come into my picc line and he says,
Hey,
you fill it yet?
Like,
nope,
keep pushing,
fill it yet.
No,
I started to fill up the second time you asked,
but I was like,
nope.
All right Phil,
yet,
nope,
nothing this time.
I definitely feel it when I'm lying because again,
if one pill is good,
I bet you tins.
Awesome.
My mindset.
Right?
And this,
the fourth time you asked me,
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
all right,
I feel it.
And he was like,
okay,
cause that is,
I don't think I've ever given anyone that much,
but they say your tolerance is really,
really high.
So you know it is what it is.
Well,
I mean I sorted the door,
didn't even shut all the way and I started hallucinating my balls off and I'm a,
I'm on so much cadamine
it on the street.
Apparently the street terminology for Special K
and I didn't even know,
like that was a thing and it was,
it was gnarly.
I mean I was seeing things that weren't there.
I was,
it was bad.
And I,
and I came out of that and I told my lease physician that came.
I said,
don't ever,
I don't want that stuff anymore.
Like that was not like,
that was not a cool,
hi.
I think it was bad.
I don't like it.
And they were like,
well,
we're going to have to put you back in the ICU.
I was like,
I do not care.
I'll live in the ICU.
It's not like I'm in the Ritz.
Okay.
If I'm in the ICU or I'm in this room with four other dude,
like it doesn't matter,
whatever.
Right.
And,
um,
obviously I'd develop,
uh,
develop a bit of a reputation at Babsi and um,
I'm,
I'm attached to fourth recon.
It was there at the time and it's right out right by Bamsee.
And there was one marine there that the day I got there,
he was right there.
It was,
I'm a staff sergeant at the time and
he told me when I got there was like a brother,
I'm gonna come see you every day.
I'm in this with you.
Well,
so did the Harlem River views the first time or major at the time said the same
thing?
Well there was a lot of cameras there,
you know,
CNN and Fox and crap cause um,
the only marine or facility,
it's got some attention.
And so that guy says the same thing.
Well I didn't see him again,
but the first guy,
the staffs are every day man,
every day.
And he started mess.
Like he would walk in and like tickle where my right foot should be and it would
tick.
It was crazy cause it would tickle and it wouldn't contact Vic come on Bro.
And he would,
he would just laugh and laugh.
You thought was the best thing ever.
And it was just those little moments though,
those little nuances of time that would lighten make me forget that I was who I
was and I was in the situation I was in that would make me realize,
you know,
if,
if I think it's that bad
I would get when I was able to get mobile,
I remember actually I was in isolation when Todd showed up,
who was the second marine?
It bancy and um,
they told me,
hey,
there's another marine on deck.
Just he's getting,
he just got here but they don't think he's going to make it my side.
I need to see,
I need to go see them right now.
Like while you're in isolation,
I do not give a shit.
I'm going to go see him right now.
We're going to have to kill me.
It's the only way I'm not seeing.
So they're like,
okay.
And they get the little human crane and train me up and put me in my black
electrical wheelchair.
I call it my black Cadillac thing.
It was legit.
They took it from you though,
is that I put one too many holes in the walls of the don't drive your electric
wheelchair and heavily,
heavily medicated folks.
It's not safe,
but I go see ty Dui.
Right.
I'm one of those too.
Yeah.
Believe it or not,
I don't want to us and uh,
but I go see ty or mind you this time,
at this point I still haven't gotten like emotional one time
since I left Doula.
Like I haven't gotten the motion from my family or otherwise.
I'm still pretty squared away with them.
Whole emotion thing.
I go see ty and I go into his room and he's completely wrapped up in the
front.
Half of his cranium was blown off.
I mean it was,
he was blind in one eye.
Severely burned.
I mean bad.
I mean,
it looked like a mummy when I saw no ears were burning off eyelids,
nose,
lips.
And uh,
I remember I had to yell at his nurse who was this giant black dude,
black army guy.
And I had to yell at him who had to then lean down and yell and the side of Ty's
head so he could know what was going on.
And I just told them,
I told the nurse when I got,
and there was like a brother just wanted to come see my family because I heard
another marine was on deck and I was like,
right on and now we can take over this hospital.
And uh,
so he leaned down and he said,
hey ty,
another marine and tie like put up as it's not like hell yeah,
marines and,
and tie whispered to the nurse.
And he said,
he wants to know like,
what are your injuries?
And I told him,
told him my injuries and uh,
started of course with a loss of her right leg,
did lose it.
I mean obviously I know where it went,
but total started with that and he was with,
he was telling ties,
I'm telling the injuries and as soon as the civil loss,
right leg like ty holds up his right leg,
like still got mine,
was it down the left leg up,
banged up Bob that holds up his left leg and it was like do this typical typical
marine banter right there considering the conditions were in yet we're just
going to smoke and joke
because that's what family does to get through the arts times you've got to find
light and regardless of how dark the situation is,
because if you don't it will kill you.
But I remember having this interaction with ty and I left the room
and I'm facing the nurse's station and when I come out and the door shuts and I
just completely and utterly broke down
to the point of anger like I was,
I was sobbing and angry.
I was so angry seeing him that way and I just like just yell like those,
those bastards like,
you know what?
Why?
What are we doing?
What are we gonna do about that?
And it pissed me off.
Well not only because here I see my brother that is never,
ever,
ever going to be remotely the same as he ever was before.
But then it reminded me
in a very abrupt manner,
who the hell are you
to be acting the way you're acting?
Because
they're telling his family,
you better call anyone who wants to tell him goodbye because he's probably not
gonna make it through the next 48 hours.
And here I was acting like a complete ass hat,
very much alive,
not having,
they weren't having to call anyone on my family or any of my friends cause I was
gonna make it at this point I'm going to make it
in.
That reminded me of it's not about you.
He just thought it was about you.
It's not about you.
And then that,
that one interaction taught me right then,
okay,
I need to go see every wounded person in this hospital as often as I can
because that's where I found healing.
So that's what I did.
I saw everyone had person talked to all of their families and that is when I
realized that gather there's really something to this service above self because
not only does it feed my soul if he's there's,
it's mutually beneficial.
I learned
if you're not willing
[inaudible]
to use whatever platform you find yourself in and to make yourself 100%
vulnerable for whatever may come,
you will never make a difference.
You were waking up and choosing to be status quo
and choosing to be average and I learned right then
the great,
the great ones,
the ones that the history books are going to rave about and that do rave about,
we're consistently uncomfortable
and consistently vulnerable.
That was a great lesson for me to learn.
They didn't make me any better than anyone else.
It just made me more susceptible to judgment,
which already had a ton of,
so I didn't care.
Mean.
I remember being in thinking about this pride of being a United States marine
and representing what that means and thinking about gunny,
you know,
the salty gunny back in Iraq and thinking how would he behave?
How would he react?
How would,
what would he do?
Same thing about first or,
I'm actually,
let's back up,
back to,
I'm going to give an example of what being tribal truly means that you can't
buy.
So I'm back in Bethesda and my dad tells me,
hey Jake,
first green's going to come see you.
And I just remember thinking,
shit,
he's,
I'm sure he's pissed cause I got hit and like he's probably just going to finish
the job.
And so I was terrified.
I'm terrified because I not only do I respect this man to the nth degree,
but I love this man
and I was like,
ah,
fuck.
I don't want to experience what I'm about to have to experience.
I'd rather take the coward's way out.
So I was like,
I'm just gonna act like I'm passed out when he walks in and I'm on a lot of
drugs that will work.
So you're knock on the door and I'm like,
I hear the door open on dad.
Say you're getting your first Soren,
how are you at first?
Sort of walks in.
So I'm like,
all right,
I'm passed out as soon as he busted the hatch and walks in my freaking heart
monitor dimes now
cause it goes from like the slow steady beat to the boo boo to the rapid beep.
And I'm like,
son of a bitch,
obviously this isn't going to work and there is no plan B.
I'm awake.
And he looks at my family and my dad's in there and my mom,
my step mom,
my aunt,
my cousins,
my brother and my sister,
I'm like,
and he says,
uh,
hey miss Schick,
how are you doing?
He's got that raspy voice.
I mean,
I'd imagine being on the drill field as long as it was,
didn't help.
And he said,
um,
no,
we're doing our,
we're hanging in there first.
Sorry.
He said,
good,
go.
Good to go.
Hey,
you want to have a minute with my brother?
And my dad was like,
sure,
no,
go ahead.
For a shorter,
like he was going to turn around,
come talk to me.
They're buying in the room and he looks right at my father and says,
yeah,
I'm gonna need y'all get the hell out.
And I was just thinking,
he's about to kill me right now over.
And he comes up to the side of my bed and remember the only thing worse than my
right arm firsthand leans down,
he puts his right arm out,
is it to like pick me up?
And so I grabbed like I,
I claps hands with him as if he's going to pick me up right.
And he puts the back of his hand on my heart and the back of my hand on his and
he leans down further and puts his forehead on my forehead and he sits there for
about three minutes.
He stands up,
he pats me on my face and he walks out
to this day,
it was one of the most powerful conversations I've ever had in my life and not
one word was spoken.
That's being tribal.
That's tribal,
that goes much deeper than team.
You can't train that.
And he walks out of the room and obviously gets emotional when he walks out.
Cause Dad walks in and I get emotional as soon as he walks up because God forbid
we tried for a one another.
You can't do that.
And my dad walks in and sees me emotional and he went,
hey,
first sergeant.
And he looks at me and like it with a puzzled look on his face and he just goes,
you marines are fricking weird.
I was like,
get out banker or you're a banker.
And it was one of those moments,
man,
that
okay.
Only people who have bear the burden of a purpose much greater than themselves.
Okay.
Willingly and openly knowing what the odds could be,
what the odds are,
what the outcomes could be.
Only the people that are willing to love all the way.
Yeah.
Regardless of the amount of pain.
Okay.
Can understand and appreciate that moment.
I mean,
and I'm proud to say that that is now the sergeant major of the United States
Marine Corps.
Yeah.
There's not a mortgage serving.
Individual I can think of.
Okay.
Cause that guy,
that guy is one of the guys I found following the blood trail
that taught me,
if you're going to love,
do it all the way.
Okay.
Don't waste anyone's time doing the halfway thing.
That was an amazing moment that I will take to my grave.
Cherishing,
knowing that,
yeah,
that guy just told me without telling me,
it's okay to not be okay.
It's okay.
At what point did you realize that the drugs were a legit problem?
The day?
How's leaving San Antonio?
The,
um,
the commanding general,
the hospitals I ended up getting,
yeah,
pretty close to it.
My time during my time there said came out and he's,
we're walking out or,
well,
he's walking,
I'm rolling.
I'm still not walking well at this point.
And he says,
uh,
I'm going to check out over it,
four,
three con.
And he says,
you know,
Jake,
I feel like we should name a hall or something after you,
after all the shit you put us through.
And I was like,
Hey sir,
let me do the infamy thing.
I'll,
I can let you let me handle.
I got it all my lonesome.
I don't need your help,
you know?
And uh,
okay.
He was like,
you know,
it's
sad to see you go,
okay.
Um,
it's,
I said,
well,
I've,
I'm,
I'm scared to death to leave.
And I remember I basically got a giant bag of drugs before I went over to four.
Three con is the last thing I did with them was signup page 11.
And um,
look,
as I,
the the higher up the told me,
you know,
I'm going to be here every day.
I told them when I thought about that,
when I thought about him and so he showed me by making me sign up page 11 and I
was like,
put it on my tab,
Bro.
What's the page 11 slap on the wrist?
Pretty much,
but you can't be promoted for,
I think it's 12 months with a page 11.
And so I was just like,
he was in DC at the time when I checked out and the gunny there was like,
you know,
hey,
he said he wanted to talk to you.
And I was like,
get him on speaker phone was talk.
And I said,
I told them when I thought about him,
it was inappropriate and I'm not sorry.
Um,
but then he's like,
give him a page 11 and gun.
He was like,
do you want to contest this?
Was like,
Hey,
I'll know.
Put it on my tab bro.
On my way out.
And um,
man,
I had this bag of drugs and my brother met up there with me and my brother's
going to drive me to Florida.
World's going to check in with Matt Sick 21.
And I knew right then because I was like,
okay,
at this point I had already started.
Like if I was eating one fence,
if I had a family member or friend,
give me a fentanyl pop out of my bag of goodies,
like I would chew,
I bite it off this thick,
trued up and swallow it and just lay on the stick and I be like,
Hey,
who's going to grab me a fentanyl?
[inaudible] they'd be like,
Jake,
we just gave him,
no you didn't.
You thought you did.
But she didn't.
I knew like,
because I was like,
hey,
listen,
if I just can't feel,
nothing matters
if I'm completely numb,
nothing matters.
And then when they gave me that giant bag,
I was like,
ah,
Shit.
I knew how it was going to end.
I was like,
yeah,
well this,
that this is a,
I don't remember,
they told me like a three months supply.
And I was like,
no,
this is like a three weeks,
blah.
And um,
man,
I started,
that's how I integrated back into civilian society was high as a kite,
knowing that if I don't have to feel,
and I can do,
go through this thing numb,
nothing matters because if you can't fill it,
who cares?
You know?
I mean,
who cares?
And it was something that really was,
um,
it just got worse and worse.
I mean,
essentially what I did for a year and a half was chased my first high.
So what I did,
and I was finally
for about a year there,
I slept with a an over and under 12 gauge shotgun.
It was condition next to my bed
every night.
And every day I talked myself out of utilizing it that in my own life too,
to where I,
I was almost to the point where I had decided why it was okay to do it and I had
justified it in my head and why it would be better
for everyone in my life
and around my circle if I was gone.
And so I,
but then I was told by family that,
you know,
Jake,
the differences between,
at this point,
I'm taking about 55 pills three times a day and I was eating between eight and
12 400 milligram fennel pops a day.
I was on enough medications to kill a village in Africa.
It was gnarly.
And the fact that I'm never roadied and I mean there's no medical explanation
for that.
And so where were all the drugs coming from?
It's easy.
You get them,
make a phone call and get them home.
Yeah.
And so it was,
that was the least of my worries on how to get the drugs cause,
but,
and to be fair,
because I was on so much as I came out of the hospital,
it took a lot to keep me where I was.
I mean,
if I,
if I'm even 10 minutes late,
10 minutes late on one dose,
I'm starting to withdraw.
I mean it was bad.
And so finally I pray,
I get told,
you know,
the difference between you living the way you're living
and eating a bullet is his time.
But the outcome's the same.
You're just slowly killing yourself.
You owe it to your brothers didn't come home.
And those that didn't still love and respect you to not only live but live well
because that's the only way you can truly honor them is by living well.
I mean that hit me hard and I realized I'm being a selfish bastard.
So what I'm,
what I'm doing,
um,
I'm carrying out every day like a victim and I'm not a victim.
I'm a victor.
I need to start acting like it.
And so I called my lead physician the next morning.
I said,
good news.com getting off all the drugs.
She said,
how are you going to do that?
So I'm just not taking the first dose,
just stop.
And she said,
I'd highly advise against that.
So why is that so?
Cause you'll probably have a massive heart attack and die.
I said,
Roger,
that planet is and no go.
What's Plan B look like?
And she was like,
you're going to have to come back to Betsy and we're going to have to wean you
off the drugs,
which is not what I wanted to hear because it was like when I left MCRD San
Diego,
I was like,
no need to ever come back here done d u n done.
And I was like,
Gosh,
all right.
And I went back there and started that process,
man.
And let me tell you something I consider until you with conviction.
I know why addicts,
they addicts
because that slow withdrawal process of getting clean.
I mean this wholeheartedly.
I don't know what was harder being blown up or getting clean.
I honestly don't know what was harder because I mean hell,
come on off the drugs.
They gave you drugs to help you come off the drugs and it's like
I just,
you know what the frick in there,
a shot or something you can give me and I can get the hell Outta here,
here and,
but there's not,
how long was the process?
Supposed to be?
Six months.
So I did two and a half.
I was clean because I was like,
I'm not,
I can't continue to be the sick that hardcore about face though.
I mean that,
that comment about,
look,
which I've said on this podcast many times like,
we got to live to honor our brothers that didn't come home.
That's the way it is.
Live.
Well,
and yet you've got to live the best possible life you can.
They don't have that opportunity.
That thought right there is what did it?
Um,
no,
because again,
it was a myriad of things man.
Cause again,
you,
that was the,
the tipping point.
But again,
it's like the people that come over and he's saying,
you know what the problem is?
Yeah.
It's like,
Hey,
I bet you there's more than one.
So that tipping point,
what are some other contributing factors and the reason I'm asking you this,
so people are listening this right now and they're feeling the way you were
feeling.
Yup.
I got a phone call about the our,
our first loss from our unit by his own hand
and I was like,
that's done more than I thought that would sting
and I can't do that to the tribe.
On top of that,
there's,
I can't,
I need to get my shit together and it's going to be ugly and it's going to be
sloppy and it's not going to be,
it's going to be the antithesis of what it should look like,
but I owe that to them.
I owe that to him.
That is when I decided that,
you know what,
I'm going to,
I'm going to try really hard
to do this life thing
the way that
I'm supposed to do it.
I mean,
I'm going to go out of my way,
okay.
To be
to where when my brother's here,
my name,
they can smile on their chest,
can swell with pride and they can say,
yeah,
that's my brother.
Okay.
Yeah,
that right there is that thing that I was talking about earlier.
Right now I don't care what anybody thinks when it comes to my brothers and what
they think.
Yeah.
That means a lot man.
That's curious shit done awake.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the stuff.
It's the stuff that will change the world.
So you,
so you go through the two and a half months and you get clean.
What's the temptation like once your queen are you,
are you feeling like,
I mean is it always there?
What is it
for awhile bro?
For Awhile it's all day.
Every day.
Every time I leave my room or I have to talk to someone rather than I'm related
to him or not,
or God forbid I have to go to like the mall or some shit.
All I thought about for a while was,
man,
this would be so much easier if files are right now
all the time.
So I thought about for a while.
What about booze?
Yeah.
Right.
So that's an easy,
uh,
that's a,
that's a pretty,
that's a pretty
okay.
Pretty good safety net in it.
Go from one bad habit to another.
And you know,
my family doesn't need help in that arena either.
And so yeah,
I was like,
hey listen,
you know what I mean,
I'm not on enough drugs to kill her,
her elephants anymore so I can,
I could probably just start drinking now.
Yeah.
So little did I realize how awesome food was when I got off all the drugs and I
was like,
oh my God,
food is amazing.
And I love it cause I was a Macy's.
Did anybody,
when I went to Iraq I easily weight,
I was probably like 222 pounds solid.
Awesome.
Some of the best shape of all zipper into my life.
I love Banksy.
I think I weighed 162
and then cause all I did was no shit.
It was drink,
Gatorade and cappuccinos.
I didn't eat ever because you feel like you're starving.
I like really hungry.
That's why there's the saying good luck.
You'll never meet a fat drug addict.
It's true because you,
your mind is going to tell you like,
oh my God,
I'm starving.
Then you eat one bite of something and it's like you ate an entire cow by
herself and it just full.
And then so I immediately,
because we need to remember too,
they're a yet,
uh,
forms of self medicating,
not just drugs and alcohol.
I mean,
it can go on and on and on.
Well,
that's something we need to remember because there's gonna be some people out
there that hear this and they're like,
oh,
well,
you know,
I don't drink excessively or I'm not on drugs.
Well,
there's a lot of other happy news.
What else?
Food.
Oh God.
I mean,
porn,
let me exercise.
I mean,
there's a million things that you could do and access
that you think is going to save you from your own head.
Yeah.
It's like an escape,
right?
Like an escape and it brings like that pleasure for that exact kind of thing.
Yeah.
You get the same,
you get the same endorphins released the same,
that same dopamine and get that same feeling of all this.
Okay.
This horizon,
because in all it is all it is
is a protection mechanism to keep you from having
to look inward and go deep into the thing underneath the thing,
underneath the thing.
It's all it is.
That's all it is.
And it's easy.
It's very,
very easy to do.
I mean,
because just being humans alone,
we were all addictive by nature.
I mean we were all,
we get to whatever it could be and so we have to be cognizant of the fact that,
you know,
there's,
we have to consistently remember that
we are all
always going to be human,
are always going to be uncomfortable with change.
Most,
most people like regimented schedules.
They'd like to get up a certain time and like the drink certain thing,
eat a certain thing,
work out a certain time,
go to lunch at a certain time.
By nature,
all of us hate change.
Anyone who's in a boat,
in a company that goes through a big transition or a big change,
you know what I'm talking about.
But we always have to remember that
just like in the marines,
we always say semper gumby.
The more comfortable you get being uncomfortable,
the happier you're going to be.
Okay.
So at what point in this,
uh,
you get clean,
what point do you decide
you're going to do something significant to try and help other people?
And you start,
yeah.
Currently to kill.
Great question.
Well,
I didn't decide it.
It was my grandmother told me,
Hey,
I you to come speak to my rotary club.
And you know,
being a man from the south,
you don't tell your grandmother now.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm going to reluctantly do this and hate it the entire time.
And I did.
And I showed up and I was easily 40 years by at least 40 years,
the junior in the room.
So I started telling my story and I'm sweating grenades so uncomfortable.
All I could think about was like,
I would love to just crush like 10 fentanyl pops right now.
And,
uh,
it was,
it was horrific.
I mean it was a freight train screwing on abortion.
It was bad,
but so it was one of those things that like,
but you can't look away type thing.
It was one of those,
but I remember walking out of there and I walked out of the building,
I'll never forgive the side of the building and I took a deep breath like,
okay,
I mean you made it.
And then when I took that deep breath,
I was like,
Huh,
I feel lighter.
You're not physically there.
My soul felt lighter.
And I was like,
oh.
Then it clicked.
That's what she was doing.
It's tactical therapy.
I get it.
That fricking broad.
She got mad because I was,
I was,
I refuse to talk to,
I talked to a psychiatrist once when I got to the hospital and then when I left
then when I was getting out of the Marine Corps for the VA process and that was
since two or three times because I had nothing to say to them because that pts
and Tbi thing,
it's not whatever,
it's not a real thing.
When I got clean
and started to drink and
I was like,
Oh shit,
this pts and Tbi I think are very,
very rural,
like very real.
And um,
uh,
move,
came back,
went back taxes and I was introduced to
a couple of guys who started a foundation down there
and they were a couple of sills are to this day,
great friends of mine and mentors of mine,
brothers for sure.
And uh,
I call him flip her one and flip her to,
and uh,
that's when I was kind of introduced to the nonprofit world and working with
warriors and their families and first responders and law enforcement officers
and their families.
And you know,
it was like,
it clicked with me like,
like I,
I like this,
I'm never going to get rich wealthy doing this.
And that's not the point.
It was,
that gave me more,
that put more of my soul tank than any pill or any bottle ever did.
Then it made me realize like,
oh,
all right,
this is the same reason I went and visited all the wounded
every time I could.
Even when we lost guys in the hospital,
like,
this is why I'm doing this,
this,
it's greater than me.
They're reminds me daily how insignificant I am.
I'm just another guy
that just choosing to do stuff that's out out of the norm.
It's hard stuff.
We had anything that doing should be,
it shouldn't be hard.
It's not worth doing alone.
And when I was working with this organization,
I was surrounded by people better than me.
By default I was better
and consistently pushed harder and harder because
I wanted to be held to a different standards again.
Because even then I wasn't waking up like,
I'm going to go out of my way to be average today.
No,
because I had to fricking navy seals that,
you know,
we're worried.
They had that really good tans and their hair had to be great and they had to
have this one type of really cool sunglasses and I was like,
Hey,
what I'm going to do is just,
I'm just going to out work these dudes.
Yeah,
I can't use a weapon anymore.
I'm not going to outrun them.
God knows I'm not going.
I'll swim,
im
a PRI can out shoot him.
My body's completely dicked up.
But
I could probably hone,
I could probably work with the most important tool.
We all have,
most important weapon we all have.
I could probably get to where I could,
I'll thank them.
So I started,
uh,
to this day it's,
it's a toss up but well with one of them,
one of them,
I pass them a long time ago,
but uh,
they know who they are too.
That's what makes it even even more beautiful.
But that's when I realized like,
all right,
I need to be,
this is what I gotta do.
This is,
this is what I'm going to be called to do
is to talk to other members of society who have been dealt whatever hand or been
dealt a blow to let them know like,
Hey,
yeah,
right now it's sucks,
but she can come out the other side
cause don't get in that deep dark rabbit hole.
Don't do that.
Because very few people come out of that.
I know because I tried it over and over again and I never got out of it on my
own.
Always took help.
And so at the time in 2012,
that's when the study came out from the VA
on average.
22 veterans a day die by suicide.
And so
another marine and um,
couple marines,
a business guy got together in Dallas and they're like,
hey man,
we got to do something.
This is,
you know,
this is,
this is our family.
Cool.
No one even knows this is a thing.
What the hell are we doing?
And um,
it's the time I'm working at a,
at a place
that focuses completely on the brain.
I mean,
I'm surrounded by
neuroscientists,
PhDs,
MDS,
and I'm learning a lot of things that
just reiterated the fact that posttraumatic stress rag,
brain injury,
these are very,
very rural things.
And I worked there for three years while 22 kill started.
And it basically started as an awareness movement and that's where the,
the pushup challenge was born.
The 22 pushup challenge that was started by 22 killed in 2012.
Just for those listeners that went viral in 2016
so you know,
overnight success is not a real thing.
And so I,
I'm working at this center the whole time and then there's some change up in
leadership at 22 kill.
And I kind of found myself drifting away from the work I was doing at the center
because it just wasn't,
it wasn't getting to the part of the soul that I wanted to be in and it wasn't
getting to that like people I've been asked,
you know,
how long are you going to speak because you give the travel schedule,
you knows it's brutal.
Right?
And I,
I thought about it for a nanosecond.
I thought,
okay,
well
when I walk off the stage,
the first time I walk off the stage and I feel like I didn't leave a piece of my
solar.
That's the last time I'll do it
because again,
it's mutually beneficial.
And if it's not,
then you're a presenter.
You're only going to fake it for so long.
People don't really,
that's why I feel like I ran a marathon when I'm done presenting for an hour,
I'm mentally,
physically and emotionally exhausted.
And if you're not,
you're faking it.
And so that's when I,
I left there and,
and you know what I learned after three years of working at that place that's
completely centered around the brain and the mind.
And it's unfortunate,
but essentially I learned after three years at that place,
so we don't know shit about the brain.
Yeah.
I mean again,
I mean I,
I,
I'm not going to candy coat it.
It just is what it is.
Why do you think we're still still spending billions and billions of dollars on
all this research and all these studies and trying to figure it out?
Cause we just don't understand it.
That's why we,
you know,
we,
you talked about Alzheimer's and Cte,
we don't even have the technology and the imaging to recognize these things in a
living human.
We put a man on the moon in 1969
can't tell you if you have CT while you're alive.
For me.
It's like,
Hey,
let's step back and look at our priorities.
Because one thing everyone's got isn't brain
everyone.
And the problem with the brain,
there's no prosthetic for that.
You get the one you got and that's it.
Why are we not hyperfocused on honing this weapon that makes us who we are?
And so the 22 guild approached me and said,
hey,
we would love for you to come run 22 kill.
We can keep the lights on for about another month and a half.
Yeah,
and you don't get health insurance and you're going to have to take Pika.
And I was like,
let me think about it.
Apps a freaking lutely.
Yes,
because I want to be able to talk
and share what I've been through with warriors at first responders and law
enforcement officers and their families and say,
hey listen,
you see that scar?
Like that one's worth it.
This one over here.
Don't do that.
That one's not worth it.
You're going to have to fight these demons.
There's no way around it,
but you can win.
You just have to keep fighting because no matter what,
no matter where you find yourself in life,
you're going to have to fight.
Cause none of us are getting up and picking out our Unicorn.
We're just not.
Yeah,
you wake up every day and it's you versus you.
And so that's why I was drawn to that.
And we had a really big first couple of years I was there
and not all cousin is gay.
Had to do with a myriad of the people,
the people that support us.
The people that say one of my biggest regrets was never sure of it.
And I'm like,
Hey,
who told you who lied to you and said that you have to wear a uniform to be a
service to your nation?
Cause you don't.
You don't.
That's a,
that's a misnomer.
I don't wear a uniform anymore and neither do you.
Neither do you.
Doesn't mean we're not serving.
I don't do what I do because it's easy.
I do it because it's hard.
The employees that worked for 26 you'll do it because it's hard.
And then the face of tremendous loss they fight on.
That's character
they're doing their dash justice does.
They're moving a mountain that our own government looks at and says,
Hey,
pick up the corner of that rug and start sweeping and look the other way.
And maybe it'll go away.
It's not going away.
What can people that are listening do to help the cause?
You know,
I got this from a buddy of mine who was actually an officer officer in the army
who was severely wounded,
um,
years ago and,
and he's,
he,
I'm going to echo it just cause he's right.
It's,
you hear all the time like I want to help.
Oh No.
Right.
I mean,
you hear it a lot from rather it's,
you know,
I want to,
I want to help save the puppies that don't have a home.
I tell people all the time,
if we were trying to raise money for dogs that died by suicide,
we'd be sitting on $1 billion.
That's true.
I mean,
it's just true.
how many dogs are screwed over a person?
Yeah,
very few.
Right?
Well,
it is what it is.
But if you want to wake up and you want to serve or you want to help,
we all have three things of value.
Every human on this entire spinning ball of shit as three things about you,
time,
talent,
and treasure.
And if you're not willing to sacrifice some of one of those three things,
you're just talking.
That's it.
You're talking.
If you want to help start sacrificing one of those three things.
I don't care if it's 22 kill,
I don't care if it's to the humane society.
I don't care.
Sacrifice
because every time we put on that uniform and our firefighters and our
paramedics and our EMT and our law enforcement officers,
let me tell me if you would feel as confident as you did going to a foreign
country,
going to Hook and Jab.
I find the bad guys and kill him.
Tell me if you would have felt as confident doing that.
Knowing
okay.
That there are people back here whom you've never met,
willing to kick in the door to your house while it is a blaze and save your
family.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I think all those people,
every single time I do this podcast and that,
that's exactly what I say for taking care of our home while we were gone.
That's it.
That's,
that's absolutely,
and so for,
that's,
that's why it's for me.
If you're not willing to sacrifice just like these men and women do on a daily
basis,
you're talking,
if there's people out there that can write a check and that's enough and that's
okay.
That's okay.
You're doing your part,
you're doing your part.
That's all right.
There are people that want to share talents.
There are people that say,
Hey,
I want to volunteer.
I'm a body.
Use me.
I'm here.
That's service.
That's sacrificing and we have a myriad of ways to do it.
And it's a beautiful thing because we're getting better and better at what we're
doing because we're not doing research and studies.
We're implementing the things that work
and we're able to tell these men and women because it's an notorious in,
in the warrior community.
And you're going to know,
right when I said,
when you see your brother,
you know,
like,
hey bro,
you good?
How are you?
I'm good.
Okay,
how do we get you great?
Cause I want you great
because greatness but gets greatness.
That's,
that's the living well piece.
Okay.
And we have to do it as a tribe together.
I don't give a shit if you ever put a uniform on the a day in your life,
if you're willing to stand shoulder to shoulder
with people that experienced trauma before the trauma and they know they've got
a thing underneath the thing,
underneath the thing,
and you're willing to say,
hey,
let's go start picking up pebbles and moving them because we'll move this
mountain and it's going to be long and arduous and the painstaking process,
but look to your left and right.
That's what makes it worth it.
And we're doing that and we're just getting better at it.
And yeah,
it's stressful.
I hate fundraising and yeah,
I hate it,
but it all comes with it.
It comes with the territory.
So some people are going to want to,
so what 22 kill.com is that the best place to go?
Look?
Yeah,
go to [inaudible] dot com read about,
learn about what we're learn about
the things that we've decided to really engage our focus on and why we're
and we're,
we're not just helping and treating the warrior or the first responder or the
law enforcement officers.
That's the,
we want the entire family.
Because
when you have,
when you pull up to the tire shop and you have four bad tires,
you can't,
you're not going to change just one tire.
Right?
He got to change it all for her.
We got to treat the family as a unit
because I'm speaking from experience,
when I say we leave a big wake in our path
and
I would not be surprised if my family has posttraumatic stress just from dealing
with me.
And the sad thing is,
is I'm not joking.
You know,
I was thinking about the nurses and doctors you left at the hospital as well as
you mentioned earlier,
if they are better people because of dealing with me,
so it's,
but I mean listen man,
we're in in just so people know,
22 kill.com another quote,
don't you have to be.org no,
no,
that's you listening to the media.
God forbid,
do your own homework and figure it out.
It's,
you can have that org.com.net doesn't matter.
That does not denote if you're a five o one c three or not just for the record
and we have our saying 22 kilo.
When I came on,
I changed it to one tribe,
one fight because you hear all the time in the military,
especially one team,
one fight,
one team would find
when I was around,
some guys are users use the word tribe and
thought about it in the more and more I thought about it.
I'll speak in one time.
I don't remember where I was,
but I went to see one team,
one fight,
but I said one tribe,
one fight sim,
because it's too easy to be a team.
If you,
if you have the same letterhead
on your business cards or you have the same in Sydney on your shirt,
that makes you a team.
The tribe goes way deeper than that.
The tribe is when my first daughter was putting his forehead against mine and
doesn't say a word
yet,
I learned a life lesson
and I get the acceptance that I was longing for without even speaking.
That's true.
Tribe is driven by the same ideals,
the same conviction,
the same passion.
I get asked all the time like,
why do you think,
why are we still at war in Iraq and Afghanistan?
Osira oh,
because you can't kill your way out of an idea.
That's why
that's what it is.
God forbid we call it that,
but just with us,
we,
so we have programs like Camp [inaudible],
which is a program where we can add,
we take a words first responders,
law enforcement officers.
The most gnarly side of it is we'll take him up in the helicopter and take them
to go kill hogs out a helicopter.
Because if you don't like that,
then you don't like freedom.
But we,
you know,
we also,
you can take him fishing,
we can take them to the range we can,
but there it's always followed up by fireside chat.
That's where the money's made.
That's where you gotta be vulnerable.
You'll get your adrenaline kick and then be willing to lower your wall and talk
about the real shit,
you know?
Then we have stay the course,
which is,
that's a traditional therapy.
That's the,
this is the you camp Bahal it'd be nontraditional stay.
The course is very traditional.
It's the one on one therapy with the warrior first monitor his or her family
and listen.
The reason that that was an attractive approach was because if you look back on
what is the most successful outcome measures as far as therapy goes and as far
as treating matters of the mind that has the best track record.
The one on one,
I think everyone on the spinning ball a k I should talk to a professional way at
least once a month.
Every single person,
and I'm saying that as the guy that I would launch my piss bottle in the
hospital at one if they came in my roof,
and I'm telling you right now,
I wish I'd have started that a long time ago because it would've saved me from a
lot of Shit I've had to deal with because I let my pride when,
yeah,
that's it.
I mean don't be afraid to say what it is.
And we started a thing called the brief program,
which is women's specific because believe it or not,
neither sex and everything
that just don't,
there's power in numbers,
but women,
when you break it down,
you break the numbers down to the bare bones.
They're leading the charge in everything in a negative light.
And that's,
I think it has a lot to do with,
they're a much smaller population when it comes to the service community.
So they're more apt to be ice to Dylan self-medication,
isolation,
you know,
and they don't have nearly as big as of an immediate tribe to depend on is we do
because there's just way less of them.
And so that's,
that's our brave program and they can go do all the things all the guys do,
but it's women's specific because they need to be empowered to,
and it's our job to help them do that without judgment.
And we also have the white SAR families program that we're building out,
which is basically you have the gold star families was started by the dod.
Well,
unfortunately the white star families don't have a seat at that table.
Why?
Star families?
They are family,
family members who fallen victim to suicide.
And we want to give them a table.
They deserve a damn table.
As you talk to those kids,
they don't give a crap out of their mom or dad died.
They just know they don't have a mom or dad.
That's enough for me.
Far be it from us to not honor someone like Lewis Puller.
Who the hell are we?
Okay.
I don't give a crap what society says.
The the how.
I should feel about that as,
let me tell you something.
This is something that everyone,
he's known unfortunately.
I bet a lot of your listeners do know already suicides,
just a word until it affects you personally.
Yeah,
she was the word
and I hear a lot where there's some corporations are owners of a mom and pop
shop while Jake,
no,
we would love to support you with 22 kills a pretty strong name.
Okay.
Souls,
cancer and AIDS
supposed to get your attention.
That's the point.
Start the conversation
cause you know you hear,
we hear all the time,
knowledge is power.
It's not,
When it's shared then it becomes powerful and I tell people dislike it.
I'll tell you if you can't support us because of a name,
if you can't look that,
pass the name to get to the root cause of an issue.
Consider yourself part of the problem,
said all you're doing is feeding a stigma that's killing the best men and women.
This nation's got the offer.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
I think that's probably a pretty good place to wrap.
We've been going for a while and especially
because you just
made very clear the reason why I wanted to have you come on this podcast now
because you know,
again,
this ties everything together that I've been talking about for the past three
podcasts.
Do you know you got a guy like Louis polar jr
and
we got to do something.
Yeah.
Cause it's still going on and you're out there and your,
your people on the front lines fighting it.
And you know,
I was watching a video that you had on your youtube channel
and it's just pictures,
pictures of soldiers,
pictures are marines,
pictures of service men and women and they're just coming up on the screen and
it's all them,
you know,
in their uniforms and overseas and back home.
And
they had,
I know what each one of those pictures is.
Okay.
Right.
So I thank you for coming on obviously.
Um,
thanks for your service and thanks for everything you've done.
Okay.
Thanks for your sacrifice and thanks for what you're doing right now.
Well,
let me tell Ya,
I learned a long time ago,
um,
is your guys like us,
you know,
the media ads and the knuckle draggers,
the,
oh Geez,
I'm sick of hearing.
Thank you for your service.
You know,
it was impossible for me for a long time to go in a public place because if I'm
wearing shorts and a tee shirt,
it's abundantly apparent.
I had a shitty day at the office.
Somewhere along the line.
It was impossible for me to get anything done.
Go Buy bread and go home without someone stopping me.
Hey,
that happened over there.
Yeah,
thank you for your service.
And I was like,
man,
it's so annoying.
I don't want to,
I just want to get bread and go home.
You will never dawned on me until a few years ago.
Maybe they're doing that for them.
Maybe it's as much for them as it is for me.
Okay.
And then I thought about why I signed up because it's cause I thought they were
worth it,
thought their families,
we're worth it.
So I was told one time,
I thank you,
I said you're worth it.
Two things happen.
The conversation ended there and secondly
they probably walked out of there a little taller than they walked in.
I was like,
oh thanks God,
I get it now.
It's not about me.
I'll tell you just like I tell all of them,
you're worth it.
Your family is worth it.
All your listeners,
I feel the same way.
Even though I guarantee you I'm going to have a million differences with a
million different album,
you're worth it.
Don't do it all again.
The moral set of bad day at the office and you know it's,
I,
I just want to leave your listeners with this is that there's power.
Just trust me when I tell you there's so much power.
Yeah.
We're about to start this thing called the tribal council,
which I think is going to,
it's a peer to peer support group and I think,
okay,
I'm praying to God that it has the power behind it that I think it does
where,
and I'm going to lead the charge.
I'll be the first one to stand up on the soapbox.
I'm just going to open up my chest cavity,
pour my soul out in front of a group of people I've never met and say,
here's the Shit I dealt with.
Here's what I've been through.
This is what I'm doing to address it,
and this is how you can hold me accountable.
Who's next?
There's a lot of power in that
because we have to remember in our community,
you hear all the time,
be accountable to yourself.
Be Accountable.
Dear brothers,
he old are your sisters.
Well,
unless you have brutal honesty first
you have manufactured accountability.
So when I ask you how you doing?
Don't tell me good to appease me because I'm going to call you on your shit.
Be Great
know.
So thank you.
I'm going to turn it back on you.
Thank you for doing what you're doing.
Cause Dude,
your,
you,
your tip of the spirit just like anyone else.
Uh,
you are leading the charge.
This wasn't easy for you to do.
Well what you had me come here do and do.
When you talked about Jesse,
when you talked about Lewis Jr,
I mean you had me,
this is not the popular thing to do,
but you said,
I've never been okay with the status quo.
Why start now?
So thank you for everything you've done and continue to do.
Well,
I'll tell you how this is a,
it's literally an honor to be able to do this.
People throw that word around all the time.
It is an honor for me to sit here.
It's an honor for me to sit here with you.
All the guests I've had on here to be able to tell these stories that I,
I'm sick sometimes that they're,
they're not carried on.
And um,
it's an honor from Yale to be able to pass on these stories so that people know
and people can learn.
And it's,
it's a humbling experience to do it as well because being in the shadow of
people like these guys,
people like yourself,
it's,
it's a humbling experience to be around warriors like that from all phases of
history.
Okay.
And we're going to keep doing it.
And when you get that program rolling,
get your ass back on here.
We'll talk about it.
We'll talk about how it's going and we'll get the word out on that thing too.
Right on.
Awesome.
Don't threaten me with a good time.
Echo Charles.
Yes.
You got quickly,
quickly,
if anybody wants to support themselves.
I have a question first,
man.
I knew that was coming.
Is that,
is that a common stereotype about navy seals?
They got to go tanning.
They need the cool side.
They need a nice here.
Not Really Jocko though.
You don't go,
you go tanning or no,
no.
The stereotypical seal thing was,
uh,
something that I didn't like.
You know,
I didn't like it.
And the older I got,
the more I disliked it.
And it's,
you know,
but it's a reality of,
especially during that during the eighties and nineties Bro,
during the eighties and nineties which is where that reputation,
but you know,
the guys in Vietnam to man those guys,
like,
like in Vietnam they wore blue jeans in the field,
you know,
because they kept off leaches and they were tougher and,
but then you don't guess what that turns into like something where guys,
some guy in 1992 is wearing blue jeans with his cammies and it's like,
oh
bro,
I showed up at the teams.
It was like,
Hey,
we,
you know,
I wanted to have long hair and be like a cool guy.
What you did?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
There's somebody just put a picture out on the interwebs of me with long hair
like circa 1990 whatever,
sideburns and everything.
Cause I wanted to be Joe cool.
And,
but what happened was,
well,
number one,
the war started.
Number two,
I started working really closely with conventional forces on my first
deployment,
a little bit on my second film and a ton.
Also,
I did multiple shipboard deployments where I worked with marines very closely,
even when I was young.
And yeah,
so I just,
it was one of those things that like when I would hear it at first I'd be like,
oh,
that's no big deal.
But then what I realized was it was a real thing when you,
when you were stereotype me as I moved into leadership positions and I would
hear that sear stereotype and I realized it was a real thing and that,
that real thing wasn't it?
It wasn't funny.
It wasn't funny because when you,
when you read or Meta a Marine Corps,
battalion commander and you have long hair or your uniform doesn't look right,
or you meet an,
uh,
an army battalion commander or an army brigade commander or,
or a senior or a gunny Sargent or company first sergeant,
when you meet one of them,
somebody that's been in the Marine Corps for 23 years and you can't put on and
blouse your,
your,
your pants and your boots.
It doesn't matter how good you are in the field.
They're looking at you and thinking,
oh,
this guy can't even blouse the boots.
I don't want them around.
That's that stereotype.
Even though it,
it had definitely was rooted in truth.
Like,
hey man,
when we got to Ramadi,
everyone had shaved heads,
everyone had squared away.
Uniforms didn't allow patches.
We've talked about that before.
You know,
we,
we had guys,
like if we could,
we put our whole element in army camouflage uniforms,
so ACU.
So they just look like army soldiers.
So I was against it.
Uh,
but I,
I get the humor of it and I,
you know,
I don't take anything that personally.
Okay.
So it's a stereotype like in at work kind of,
I thought he meant maybe like out at the club or whatever.
Like you know,
navy deals tend to be
more into it.
Yeah.
You know what's funny is,
you know who made a joke about this,
Tim Kennedy,
we were,
here we are recording the podcast.
Tim Kennedy was literally doing a photo shoot.
He was like,
and he's got long hair and he was like all,
you know,
I'm not like a Hollywood.
And I was like,
Dang Dude,
I'll tell you why.
Let me give it,
give you the,
the Barney version of everything he just said.
This is one of the things I dig about Jocko and it has nothing to do with this
following or what he did.
It's because,
okay,
cause he ever,
he's authentic and he's intentional and everything that he does
and
we should long to be around that a lot more.
Yup.
I'm going to have to go ahead and agree with you on that one.
So that's when you sort of learned,
hey,
heres just to look good.
This is after you shaved your head,
by the way.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Dude,
It doesn't mean anything else.
I'm here to win.
That's what that was.
It's cool.
That was me growing up in the teams.
Yeah,
I know.
That's why Tim,
Tim Kennedy,
he's going to hear this leaky funnel making fun of my,
well,
he was making fun of my,
uh,
people.
Yeah,
your people.
My people having long hair,
but he had long hair and doing a photo shoot.
You know who said that?
You Know Matt best or I met Beth on one of his videos.
He's the,
he,
he alluded to that.
Oh,
it's no,
it's real.
No,
it's a real thing.
And Tim Kelly does 100% right,
because,
because yeah,
there's,
there's some seals where you're like,
oh,
I know Brian.
Hundred percent let me tell you one thing.
I just object to it in a,
you know,
real strong way
what
somebody's using some kind of hair product,
right?
Like,
that's,
that's a no more than Tanny.
That's a no,
no one actually Tan.
So that's not a real thing.
Oh,
it's the real thing.
I was allowed on the org in the 90s and there was the,
there was the marine recon guys and they straight up had the foil like
reflectors under their chins out when they were suntanning.
I got a kick out of that,
but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if they that there was a dozen recon marines out in,
in Speedos,
right.
Straight up tanning with baby oil.
It doesn't matter.
They're,
the reality was the seals were default Hollywood tanning guys got,
that's the way it is.
That's okay.
That's what you gotta deal at the same time,
Bro,
too.
Let's be very clear that it's
me saying it or Tim Kennedy or Matt or that's one thing.
Okay.
But if like if Joe public civilian says something,
it's like,
hey bro.
Yeah,
I don't know that that's,
I don't know that Joe would actually
know that.
That's why if we rolled out,
oh,
if we rolled out all the stereotypes for the services,
like marines,
dumb jarhead,
a cradle to cradle,
the cran thing,
that's the big marine corps one Crayon,
crayon heater.
Yeah,
they eat crayons.
I said that's like legit thing.
The,
the army's got there,
you know,
who are things and you know,
we don't have that kind of all,
all that kind of thing going on.
A Green Berets,
you know,
smoking cigarettes,
that's what the seals would say.
Like,
Oh yeah,
they're over there smoking cigarettes and eating donuts.
You know,
so it,
there's just little stereotypes that have some,
some basis of reality,
but you know,
you can't put a stair.
So that's why stereotypes are stereotypes or some level of reality to it.
Um,
but there,
the reality is that you can't blanket a whole organization with any of those.
So that's the way it goes.
Right.
The next time you go tanning
you solid juggling 10
cleared that up.
Thank you for that course.
And I,
yeah,
I can talk about some ways to support the podcast as well.
Do you know?
Do you know what this is?
I'm going to teach you something right now.
You ain't got when the train?
No,
no,
no.
The,
the big,
the big grill in the field.
It means or pick it up.
Pick up the pace.
Gotcha.
Alright,
let's do it.
cool.
Well if you want support the spot.
Yes.
And Yourself.
Of course.
We're doing a double thing.
Go to origin main.com.
Okay.
This is where you can get Jocko supplements for your joints.
First of all,
that's,
that's a big one.
Who you,
you know what you're starting to sound like,
just so you know what?
Not the radio guy.
100% but I sound like a radio.
That was 100% thanks Jake.
Redo it here.
You were like,
alright.
Alright.
I believe you.
Okay.
Origin main.com Maine,
the state Maine origin main.com.
This is where you can get Jocko supplements.
Super Krill oil for your joints.
Important.
Super important.
Yup.
That was good.
Solid proof and it's true by the way.
Also another to supplement called discipline.
That's what's this?
This one is right here.
It's like a cognitive enhancer,
amping,
you know,
some caffeine in there,
some good stuff.
Some is there.
There's some vitamins in here.
This is a good one,
is a really good one.
I mean,
take before you do some something that you gotta use your brain and your body,
which is cool.
All so
milk,
milk is out.
It's a protein powder.
Jocko.
What?
Believe it or not,
I did two and two.
I got it.
I put it together.
One that crafty.
Wow.
There it is.
Boom
and monk.
Tasty.
Yeah.
Mint chocolate chip.
And wait,
wait,
you're coming out with a new uh,
but that we're working that those won't be out for a little bit.
There's new discipline coming out.
It's a new flavor.
One of the flavors.
Yeah.
One of the flavors is it's,
I don't know if this is okay,
right.
We might have to rebrand it something else because it can't be Jocko.
If it is coconut,
pineapple is tasty.
Okay.
So here's,
so here's one of those.
I can't believe it.
So anyway,
so Jocko was hardcore,
right?
Authentic,
authentic,
hardcore.
Right.
Okay.
So one of the main important issues with developing these supplements,
which are good supplements by the way,
is taste.
Does that hardcore,
does that seem hard?
Cornea?
He thinks that I would like eat.
When I originally was making supplements,
he thought that that my,
I would have no priority on tastes.
Like if it tastes bad,
doesn't matter.
Right?
Does it matter?
It's actually better if it tastes
okay.
I wasn't thinking,
but you could think that in order to drink this,
you just got to get,
like,
you just gotta Grit your teeth and get some intentionally like,
hey,
if that happens,
it happens.
Kind of like,
I don't feel that way because the reality is when,
when supplements tastes like crap,
you don't need it.
So then what's the point?
So there you go.
A flank.
That's what he did.
That's what that is.
The flank with the taste nonetheless tastes good.
And I think Pina Colada,
pineapple,
coconut,
whatever.
I think that's a good idea.
Wait,
homage to,
uh,
our Hawaii route route,
all my people in Hawaii.
Yes.
And Mark,
by the way,
is a mint chocolate chip.
Mint chocolate.
There's no chips,
no chips.
Good point.
Same,
same kind of feel your I've never heard without the chips.
It's Kinda
tough to deal with it.
It will taste good though.
We can,
we can call it test.
Good reports are in good.
Very good also.
Oh,
I hear good things about the mixability too.
No,
just all great deal by the way.
Yeah,
it's a pain in the ass.
Also gies in rash guards were still an origin main by the way.
Dot Com where didn't mean Daca?
GIEVES and rash guards.
If you're into Jujitsu,
when you get into Jujitsu you can have the question and I still,
we still get that going.
What?
Gee,
should I get?
Get on word you and G,
boom.
There you go.
Also rash guards,
compression gear and sweat suits and whatnot.
Most comfortable sweatsuits in the world.
Proven 100% also the immersion camp that you did,
sue immersion camp,
boom in Maine,
Lake Echo layers
one week,
two sessions starts August 26 and September 2nd Lafe will be there.
Dave Burke will be there.
I will be there.
Jp is JP is going to be scheduling.
Trying to schedule it at this time.
Wait,
so life is going,
is it going?
And of course you can't say like full confirmed cause flights aren't booked yet
or whatever.
But when I talked to Lisa other day,
he was,
let's just call it real fired up.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the plan.
Boom.
Late in the game.
Um,
Dave of course meet.
Yeah.
And,
and Jack was going,
no engine grip.
No.
Is your rep this time your honor old jockeys.
It'd be good.
Um,
go to origin main.com to see all of these things and uh,
you know,
you see something you like get something also on [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko
you can get fitness gear,
kettlebells,
steel bells,
jump ropes,
a lot of good stuff on there.
I've got some soap from them.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Just to see what it was.
You know,
they have some good stuff.
Approve or disapprove and he use it yet.
Just cue me in.
I'll report back.
I promise.
Island.
Good,
good sweat on it.com/jocko also,
when you buy these books,
fortunate son marine life of chesty puller or any of the books that Jocko
reviews on this podcast.
What he did,
I went to a Daca pod or Jocko podcast.com little section called books from the
episodes.
Got them all listed there by episode.
Click through there,
boom ticket,
Amazon shop.
Buy those books or a leaf blower or whatever.
He isn't going to buy.
Just carry on shopping.
That's your thing.
Good way to support.
Very good,
very good.
Also,
the alternative is we do like 40 minutes of advertisements in the beginning.
I don't have a problem with that.
That's not happening.
Well,
yeah,
you're kind of
ty advertisements as far as advertisements go.
Even like on you,
you know how when you're watching youtube videos of the ads in the,
in the beginning of the video
I have youtube red.
Do you have youtube red too?
Is that what's going on?
I don't.
Youtube red is the best $9 and 99 cents a month.
You can spend your press click and it just starts playing the video.
No advertisement.
It's,
here's the thing,
I don't mind the advertisements.
That's how I find out about like a bunch of the new movies that come out.
A lot of like,
um,
intermittent.
This guy's weird.
I had a guy the other day,
he was like,
I was watching,
he was watching one of the podcasts and it was one of the heavy podcasts,
which I guess doesn't really narrow it down too much,
but he's,
he goes,
you got to walk into podcasts and all of a sudden there's a big advertisement.
Oh,
you know what?
This is what youtube will do.
Sometimes with longer videos.
They'll just put that in where this guy was angry and you know what can do.
It was in the youtube comments,
which we know we don't respond to,
but we do read.
But I almost responded bro.
Nine 99 90 99 that thing's gone.
I was watching videos series for,
for old shit.
Right.
It is,
it is.
It is fee.
But it was going great.
And then the commercial pop check into my life.
I'm never
again when I did,
I did the ads.
I get it though.
You know,
cause sometimes you look,
you're listening to his deal,
his thing,
whatever it is he's talking about.
It takes you mentally and kind of this face it emotionally into a certain spot
and then the feeds out into some,
hey do you want to,
I don't know,
whatever the ad is,
you know,
you want to get more color.
It kind of puts the brakes on that.
There's been some unusual things in the podcast,
especially for Echo.
I'll say ACLU has been very,
and Ed,
we didn't talk about it cause it was actually not the right time to talk about
it.
But on the last podcast,
one 22,
there was an emotional moment for echo and a amen.
You got through it.
I know and I'm like super hardcore and everyone knows that,
you know.
But Hey man,
you've been the strongest.
There are moments of fatigue.
No one else maybe just fatigued that time.
Maybe.
Anyway,
we're going to change this
two sub,
uh,
a support is subscribed to the podcast.
If you haven't already on iTunes,
stitcher,
Google play,
and any other place or wherever you listen to your podcast with a new podcast
apps all over now.
So boom,
subscribe.
No shame.
Can't keep up on them.
Yeah,
and when I say no shame,
that's not a in Hawaii or actually here's something a little interesting thing
starts super interesting.
It's kind of interesting.
You know the expression no shame,
right?
It usually means like by this guy has no shame.
Like he's kind of low.
Like he,
he has his moral standards may be kind of low,
something like that.
Right?
In Hawaiian,
no shame means don't be shy.
I like in South Africa when I was in South Africa,
they say shame,
shame.
It's just a word that they use for all kinds of different things.
I'm like,
Oh,
shame.
No kidding.
It's,
I liked the way they used it.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I'll try and bring it back.
I'm telling you right now with those two pieces of information,
right?
I'm prepared to change.
It'll help.
It'll help communication.
You get a guy from boy and he says,
no shame.
Does it mean it in a bad way?
Cause it's,
they're very subtle differences,
but one is kind of on the bedside like,
oh this guy,
no shame,
you know this guy,
no shame if a hole,
the guy from Hawaii says no shame is he's just saying don't be shy.
Or if he's telling the story,
say,
Hey,
this person wasn't shy at that point.
Like,
like if he says,
and here it is,
here's the example.
Okay,
I'm telling a story,
but a guy who went and talked to a girl and said by this guy,
no shame,
he just went and talked to her on the mainland or you know,
outside of Hawaii or whatever.
They'd be like,
wait,
what was wrong with him?
Was that his friend's girlfriend or something?
Or was that his cousin or something?
You know what I mean?
So it sounds like a whole different story.
So saying do that in text message there.
Then if it's a Hawaii guy,
you can go for same problems.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
which you may not know if he could probably do it because he is very proactive
and aggressive in his use of emojis.
This guy.
Yeah,
rainbow spirit like Google's brings it.
I incorporate the palm tree to very recently so watch out for that one.
Yes.
Nonetheless.
Back to support youtube channel.
Also along with the podcast plastic and platforms and apps you do.
We do have a youtube channel where kid podcasts that you do panel now.
Oh boom.
Just released warrior kid Youtube Channel podcast where the blood gas,
yes.
Can kind of deal but just work.
It's hosted yet.
It's up and running live.
Okay,
so I kept you on the lookout for that one.
But yeah,
Youtube,
the,
we have the video version of this podcast won't see what Jake looks like and
some good looking guy.
He talks about their moneymaker during the podcast and I want to come check it
out.
Guys got curious.
You could don't deny it.
One of the first things I did was ask somebody in my family,
I was like,
I need a mirror.
I haven't seen my face.
And I was like,
I it,
how bad is it?
I saw it and I was like,
Nah,
we're good.
You can still work.
Boom.
Yeah,
so if you guys curious,
curious about that bone.
We got the youtube channel.
Perfect.
All Scott excerpts on there and enhanced excerpts.
I take little extra and put music on it.
It's nice,
I think.
Nice chocolate fix.
Nice.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I good.
Some of them.
Hell yeah.
Also,
Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store.
Creatively enough,
Jocko store.com this is where you can get tee shirts and whatnot,
whatnot,
meaning rash guards as well.
Hoodies,
hats,
all kinds of cool stuff.
I think they're cool.
I love it.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's good.
Jocko.
store.com on the year it's Jocko gear on Jocko stores.
Yeah.
Fully nonetheless.
Look with this one.
I'm not saying,
Hey,
go to Joel store.
Buy some time.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying just go there and look.
Check it out.
You like something,
get something.
That's a good way to support.
That's all I'm saying about,
because store also,
I love it.
It's good.
Yeah.
Also psychological warfare.
Okay?
You're going to know what that is,
is what it is.
It's an album with tracks.
Chocolate tracks,
not a song.
They're not songs and singing.
You don't want other than that,
no,
we don't.
Playing Guitar.
Maybe that's kind of quite than he played guitar.
None the less.
It's not that.
It's chocolate talking and here's what he's saying,
Kate.
We call it our campaign against weakness,
right?
Just you know,
you're on the program,
you're on the path that you can get me in shape.
You're staying in shape.
You're whatever you're doing right.
You're reading more.
I Dunno.
Waking up early,
right?
Impose the discipline first thing in the morning,
whatever,
whatever you do,
and do that every day.
Those days where you're feeling weak,
you might skip the workout,
but asleep in whatever,
whatever the weaknesses,
there's a track for it and it's Jocko telling you why you shouldn't give in to
that weakness.
Just for that time.
It's not him yelling,
nothing like that.
It's just kind of explaining to you why you shouldn't,
shouldn't give in through effective too,
by the way,
a hundred percent effective.
I'm not mistaken.
That was the last numerical report.
Percentage wise.
Well,
you know you just mentioned very quickly the warrior kid podcast.
Yeah,
and that has a youtube channel and in order to have a youtube channel for the
warrior kid podcasts,
there has to be a warrior kid podcast,
which there is now for your kid.
Podcast is out and in it it is questions for Uncle Jake,
by the way,
not this uncle Jake,
but a different uncle Jake.
I'll tell you it's similar
and it's on a separate channel.
The reason I put it on a separate channel is so that your kids aren't sitting
there streaming podcasts or your kid podcasts and all of a sudden they jump into
machete season or the meal masker so it's totally separate channel.
Uncle Jake's got some lessons learned for kids.
Yes,
definitely for parents.
Very true.
Hundred percent coming from Echo Charles for teachers.
Yes.
Coaches.
Human beings.
I'm going to go ahead and say yes real quick about what else think do well is
listening to it where it's okay,
this is why it's for like a parent because these kids like that asking you the
questions.
They're questions.
They probably asked their parents.
Maybe the parents would be like,
oh,
I'm not sure.
Maybe,
or,
okay,
I'll just kind of spontaneously answered the question.
Meanwhile,
it's like,
Kinda Yerba is good man.
It's good.
It's getting,
there's no,
that happens to be number one.
Number one,
kids,
podcasts,
kids and family,
Pumpkin,
so that's cool.
All right.
Uh,
speaking of way of the warrior kid,
there's the book way of the Warrior Kid and there's also the new book.
Boom.
There.
It is hardcover way.
The warrior kid to Mark's mission,
Uncle Jake continues to help mark with some of his problems,
losing his temper,
how to handle being made fun of.
Don't you wish somebody told you how to handle being made fun of when you were a
kid?
I know I would've liked that.
Fear of failure.
How do you overcome that?
Also learns about the value of money.
A lot of people don't know that these days.
A lot of kids don't know that for sure.
Yeah.
Mark in the book actually gets a job,
makes money.
Refurbishes a bike basically gets after it,
so give the children that you know the ultimate gift and that is the gift of
discipline.
Show him the way of the warrior kid and you will be stoked.
Speaking of warrior kids and soap,
what you mentioned earlier or you could get from on it,
you could also get soap from Aiden.
He's a warrior king.
Very good on that.
Irish oaks ranch.com stay clean.
That's the motto.
I'm sure don't forget about this clinic was freedom field manual and y'all,
I'm actually glad I wrote this book.
You want to know why?
Because I actually have to refer to it.
Oh Dang.
That's kind of reacting to I.
You're going to it like Dang.
Like you didn't think I had to refer to.
Did you think I didn't have to refer to it?
I think I never thought about whether or not yet to refer to,
but now that you mentioned it's kind of like,
oh I get it.
You know how you got to write your to your to do list.
Look boy you to remember that.
It's kind of like that.
I I have to refer to the manual.
It's a good book man.
It's you open it up for your pitch is good.
Read two pages.
That's the way I wrote it.
I wasn't even thinking about like the effectiveness of it.
It's pretty cool man.
If you want the audio version,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
It's not on audible because olive oil wouldn't work for a book like this.
It needs to be an album with tracks so it's available on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP,
three platforms.
Then there's extreme ownership of course combat leadership applied to the
battlefield,
applied to business,
applied to life.
Do you do overs?
1 million copies sold right now.
That's pretty cool.
Impressive.
Yeah.
We're stoked on that and it's been,
it's the best selling and I forget there's some kind of a cool bestselling
leadership books since its release or something like that.
I forget what the actual thing but it sounded pretty cool.
They sent me a stat thing today.
That's why I know this stuff.
Get it for your business in life and also you can right now order the follow on
book two extreme ownership that I wrote with my brother Leif Babin.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership.
It is finding the balance as a leader and I talk about this all the time on the
podcast,
I actually said,
I actually talked about this in the first public interview I ever did with Tim
Ferris.
He asked me about the qualities of leaders.
As I said balance.
So while that's what I'm talking about as we continue to work with companies and
businesses,
people like the hardest thing people have,
the hardest challenge people have is balance.
I talked to ton about that with the talking about chesty puller.
So much balance.
He balanced perfectly between between being hard and being gentle.
He found that perfect balance cause you know if you're gentle,
gentle,
as a leader,
you're a pushover.
No one respects you cause too hard.
As a leader,
you drive people to hard.
You're slave driver.
No one likes it.
No one respects you.
You got to find that balance.
That's what this book is about.
And if you need QRF at your company,
Quick Reaction Force,
right?
If you need some support,
some help with your leadership,
well contact the quick reaction force for your team.
It's called national on front.
That's my leadership consulting companies.
Me,
it's life,
Bab and JP Denelle.
Dave Burke website is echelon front.com.
We solve problems through leadership.
Boom.
If you've got a problem,
it's leadership.
Of course,
the muster leadership seminar zero zero five is in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th and zero zero six seven in San Francisco.
October 17th and 18th d c is close to being sold out right now.
It might be sold out.
There might be a few tickets left,
but if you want to register extreme ownership.com get in the game with us.
I will not be in the presidential suite eating chocolate covered strawberries
and drinking fizzy water.
I will not be doing that.
I will be with you if you come to the monster.
I'll be with you hanging out,
eating lunch,
working out,
talking,
answering questions the whole time.
You know?
No Green Room.
Lafe same way.
J P same way.
Dave,
same way.
Echo Charles,
same,
same way.
Your company,
any one of those if you want to.
They're fun.
Yeah.
We've got something in Dallas too.
If you want to come to that.
It's called the roll call.
It's for police,
law enforcement or military.
You want to come hang out,
do whatever you want to do.
You can just come BTF around,
get after it.
That's cool with us.
And that one is September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
That's also register on extreme ownership.com and until it's perfect,
it's perfect.
You got something on?
Yeah,
so I got hit September 20th Oh our gala is September 22nd in Dallas.
We're good.
We'll see you there.
Right on their locked.
You're all coming.
Oh Dang.
We'll come do your thing.
And you come to Oh,
dies will crash your party.
You crashed mine.
Hey again.
What's a good time?
They'll be awesome.
Uh,
and until we see you at the monster or the role car call or at the immersion
camp in Maine,
if you want to cruise with us kind of hard,
you can find us on the inner webs on Twitter,
on Instagram and on pat face.
Jake,
listen to this one.
Jake is at Jacob Underscore Schick,
which is spelled like s chick case.
Anyway,
I say always say Schick,
like the razor,
no relation.
I got screwed on that deal.
Oh yeah,
you got left out in the cold on that one.
The dude that started,
it's named Jacob Shick.
I googled your name like a couple of weeks ago and I was reading about Jacob
Shick.
Hmm.
One of these days I'm going to overtake.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
Echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
Echo.
You got anything else?
No ma'am.
Thank you.
So cool to meet you too.
Row feeling's mutual brother.
Jake,
any closing thoughts?
Yeah,
I forgot to say,
by the way,
and I will get scolded if I don't that if you buy our merge,
I need you to know that that's how we pay our overhead,
our merchandise sales and the merchandise available@twentytwokill.com 22
kill.com and restarting a wind therapy program through partnership of JMP
cycles.
Did you say what kind of therapy?
Wind does that all about?
The breeds between the knees,
Bro.
Oh,
motorcycle.
okay.
You got it.
See,
you took it.
You are going to take it to a weird place.
No,
I was taking the free fall.
Oh yeah,
I was taking it.
Freefall.
How is that a problem with say,
knees and the breeze with jumping out of the things that didn't need jumping out
of that was just like,
no,
no gravity.
No Man.
Listen though,
I don't.
I would just leave people with this like,
hey listen,
it
just keep grinding,
so it's all about you know,
you.
I've learned
that I've learned this in my well versed and experienced 36 years of life.
Three things.
This lives absolutely worth living.
What makes it beautiful is you get to share it with people that you love,
all the way your successes and your failures,
and three,
it's not about you
live wall check.
Well Jake,
as I said before,
thank you for coming on the show,
but more importantly,
thanks for your service in the Marine Corps.
Raw thanks for your sacrifice.
Thanks for fighting so hard and thanks for what you are doing now to help
veterans continue to live the lives they deserve to live
and to everyone out there,
whether you're a veteran or not,
I said at the beginning of this series
that this was a story of war and love and pain and death.
Life is hard.
It is tragic.
Yeah.
Immerse merciless.
And when you are caught in that storm,
okay,
you might not see anything else beyond the darkness,
but there is light beyond the darkness.
But you have to hang on,
you have to hang on and you have to move forward and you have to fight.
You have to fight,
fight through all that pain and fear and darkness
and get to the other side.
Yeah.
Where the darkness subsides
and where you can once again
live.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for living
and thanks for getting out there
and getting after it.
So until next time,
this is Jake Schick and deco and Jocko
out.